uh so I I I don't know how to say this
so I'll try bear with me if you have
children in the room your muffs okay so
the breaking story is that a Democrat
staffer on the on a senate hearing room
floor filmed himself and another man
let's just say enjoying each other's
company quite a great deal and there's
video of it all over X everyone keeps
posting the article because the video is
out and uh everyone's like well
unsurprising that it's a Maryland
Democrat Senate staffer who uh I will
just just to you know so you understand
filmed he and another man enjoying each
other's company quite a great
deal on the Senate hearing floor uh and
that's the story we're leading with
because it's Friday and uh we're ready
to laugh but I do think it matters
because we're going to be talking a lot
about uh January 6 and what's to come in
2024 and there are a lot of stories
about how this is going to go down uh
considering they just arrested or
they're planning to arrest this
journalist uh on Tuesday Steve Baker so
it's going to get pretty interesting and
that uh uh you know we we do have Owen
SCH joining us who uh recently got out
of prison over this stuff so we will get
into all that but before we get started
my friends I got big news head over to
the best song ever.com buy the song
click download your own price it's 69
cents or you can give whatever you want
and when you
you will get a promo code emailed to you
you must look in the file there will be
a unique code you can use to get 35% off
any purchase or subscription at cast
brew.com so you're basically you're
getting a deal look 69 cents for the
song but you can end up saving 20 30 40
bucks hey maybe you want to buy 100 bags
of coffee you end up saving yourself 35
bucks well actually that would be more
than that 100 bags of coffee that's a
lot of coffee you're going to be saving
yourself like hundreds of dollars and if
you subscribe with the code you will
retain that discount forever even if you
end the subscription later and come back
and restart you will still get that 35%
discount here's the thing buy the song
Because this is our team up with the
daily wire this is Jeremy boring and
Michael ns' song we made a modern
version and this like it's it's a modern
version it's like synth pop you'll
recognize it and uh the big news is we
debuted at number one top of the charts
this morning I wake up and they're like
hey you're number one on iTunes and I'm
like okay that's great we need to sell
you know tens of thousands of these and
uh uh and then continue to smash our way
into the music industry and tell these
these big wigs fat cats and Gatekeepers
they can't do anything about it I I want
let you guys on I want to tell you
something I've pitched this numerous
times saying jere here here's what
happens with Jeremy boring they tell him
100 times the market rate to play a song
one time was no good we assume he
offered
$150,000 to play one song one time and
they told him no so instead he spends
the money to make a spoof song to B
basically as an Fu we team up with them
doing a modern version for similar
reason because when we put out our song
we got emails back from entertainment
press saying go f yourself and I'm like
I'm very determined now to force our way
into these charts so they have no choice
but to write about it but I want to tell
you something else even though three of
the four songs we've published have
charted on Billboard they go into my
Wikipedia page and they remove the chart
numbers to make it look like the songs
are not successful that's how dirty and
driven these people are so buy the song
of the bestsong ever.com and contribute
your uh
to get help us me uh Carter Banks jery
boring and Michael nlls give that middle
finger and you'll get a you'll get a
discount smash the like button uh
subscribe to the show become a member at
timcast.net
yeah right on and uh uh you want to just
do a quick introduction well sure uh you
know I'm one of the most politically
persecuted journalists in America I
don't think it's a stretch to say that
and I got out of prison last week for a
speech crime and the last time I was
here on timcast we we were discussing
this before we went live how basically
my case was going to be used as a
president setting case to go after other
journalists and now they are going after
other journalists there's another one
that's going to be turning himself in on
Tuesday and I suspect there's going to
be a lot more in 2024 so my case is
eventually likely to get to the Supreme
Court and hopefully we can have success
there to stop this political persecution
of journalists in Biden's America and
I'm sure we'll get into some of the
details about uh my case and everything
else we'll get into that later but I
would just say that I I'll I'll lead
with this there's something that I can't
get get over now it's like an itch that
can't be scratched and and I'm not
somebody that censors myself I don't
censor myself I'm not afraid to speak my
heart I'm not afraid to speak my mind
but just coming on this show just doing
the interviews I've done this week just
hosting my show over at Infowars now
every time I go on air and every time I
speak there's something in the back of
my head am I going to go to jail for
this am I going to get arrested for this
am I going to be incarcerated and
tortured and thrown into solitary for
this and that's what it's like to grow
up in a communist country that's what
it's like to grow up in an oppressive
regime and this is what it's like in
America now and and it it breaks my
heart that this is the country that
future Americans might grow up in that's
the thought that has to linger in the
back of their mind like they're living
in North Korea that if they say
something wrong they have bad speak or a
thought crime they're going to be locked
up so hopefully we can stop this before
it just gets totally out of control
right on man should be fun uh Eric
July's back what's up what's up man
what's up how you doing I mean I'm done
this is my third show today man I'm
feeling good right yeah yeah yeah I'm
feeling good though are you what do you
do man uh you know obviously
everything's been crazy with this whole
rip averse thing man blessed to be in
the position that that we're in uh with
this company and and being able to talk
about it freely man and and um you know
job opportunities we're creating we
talked a little bit about that this
morning you made you launched the comic
book Universe yeah and it's uh again
mult I mean we're on our third million
dollar campaign here which is kind of
insane um again I kind of still got to
pinch myself every every day kind of
realizing that this is a real thing this
is happening uh but yeah it shows this
there's a demand for it man but it does
feel good to be be back here hadn't had
a chance been busy but uh you know it
feels yeah we had you over on the
culture War this morning yeah but uh now
we're going to talk news so thanks for
hanging out should be fun as well and of
course Luc is here hey guys my name is
lcer dski of youtube.com wear change and
we are bringing back thug life with of
course the Tupac mellian Killuminati
t-shirt that I'm wearing right now that
you could get on the best poitical
shirts.com we probably all will be in
the goog but we're all going to be
together if you want to support me the
best way to do that the best political
shirts.com also the best way to do some
holiday shopping because you do that's
why I'm here thank you so much for
having me and I'm Ian Crossland blasting
through your Consciousness to say hello
to you through the interwebs uh and I
wanted to clarify anyone that's buying
the song The Best Song Ever in order to
get the coffee coat I believe you have
to buy it from the best song.com some
people went to like Amazon music or
iTunes they was like where's the code
you got to buy it from the best song
ever.com If you want to get that 35% off
your coffee so do it there best song
ever.com right yeah so that's why I said
go to the best song ever.com you buy it
there you buy it with the download
button right there uh cuz that's that's
that's how you get it and then what
happens when you buy the song you get
the song and you get a folder that has a
file with the code in it so get it and
the code is good for two weeks and it's
good on anything and everything and you
can subscribe to a coffee purchase let's
say you do one bag per month you're like
I'm going to subscribe to this coffee
for one time you get the discount
forever and when you put that song on
Just take a sip of that coffee and
realize how it's all
connected right on Ser is here thanks
guys for tuning in uh excited for the
Friday show let's get to it kind of
crazy so here we are uh this is this is
the news and um Senate staffer caught
filming gay sex tape in Senate hearing
room graphic the image is blurred
heavily thank
God but it's not blurred all over the
whole image not just the whole image is
blurred not just the not quite blurred
enough so uh they know who this guy is
now his name is flying all over the
place there's that wasn't everything
flying all over the place dude the daily
The Daily Caller posted the video of it
like it's it's everywhere sadly on
social media what this this guy needs to
get like I don't I know man 20 years
like like you know we we're talking
about they want to lock up Enrique tario
he wasn't even in DC on January six and
I'm like this is a guy who probably
broke so many laws he's got to get
locked up it's not just him it's it's
two guys and they're enjoying each
other's company quite a great deal if
you know what I'm saying filming it in
the Senate hearing room I'm not like
bullish on law on laware and warfare
through law but like at some point you
got to make a precedent don't do this
kind of thing on the Senate hearing
flooor I just guys when I said 2024 was
going to be crazy I did not see this one
coming I I thought it was going to be
like a journalist gets woken up at 6:00
in the morning and they did not see this
one coming you're just asking you just
got puns left and right tonight man did
they come on set up a camera and then
like go get in the middle of the room
and get on some like one of the guys I
guess has a see you know he everybody's
getting mad at me cuz I'm on X and I'm
like is the guy you're naming the dude
being filmed or the dude doing the deed
Tim really cares about the details here
I just want point that out and I do care
I do care so I did watch the video I AB
slow motion rewind try to figure out
back and for and and you know not that
that much Luke you know you can calm
down I don't know what you were watching
but uh listen I've seen videos of people
brutally murdered I have watched people
die in front of me and well that's
probably hyperbolic I've watched people
die a great distance away from me from a
height I don't want to make it seem like
I was standing in front of a guy who
died I've been shot at so when this news
breaks that a Democrat staffer there's
two guys and they're going at it and
then I see a bunch of people saying this
is the guy I'm like hold
on is is they said this guy filmed
himself doing this thing and I'm like
how do you know that's actually him it
was an older guy too right no no it's a
young guy it was a younger guy young guy
so here's here's the issue so I so I
half jokingly tweeted but have seriously
uh I'm not going to say exactly what I
said cuz it was graphic but I I
responded to Greg uh was it Greg price I
think I said he said here's the guy who
did it I said is he the guy who's
getting or the guy giving and everyone's
like haha oh I'm like no this matters
because the dude the dude doing the deed
is wearing some kind of like head
mounted camera so you can't see his face
and the issue is if they've gotten
information through other means outside
of the video that the guy filming which
they said this guy filmed himself doing
it that's implying the guys who face you
can't see is doing it and the guy whose
face you can't see is not him that means
there's another identifi unidentified
guy and I'm like the last thing I'm
going to do is call a guy out on a show
like this as having you know enjoyed
another man's company in a in a public
building unless I know for sure that's
the case but wait a second so there's so
there's a couple interesting facts that
you just laid out so this person had a
head-mounted camera deal I think that's
what it was on a GoPro G GoPro so I mean
likely not the first time this
individual has done it may be in the
building but don't you need you have to
have special pass to get access to that
part of the building too so it had to be
another staffer of somebody well they
could let him in a lot of people on
social media are saying that this was
the real Insurrection that has happened
I TW I tweet
Insurrection Insurrection is trending I
think right now
also it and Schumer saying erection
inside of the erection is is trending as
well I'm guessing these are not the
first two men to um you know insert in
the exit hole in the in any of the
capital buildings but they might be the
first to film it probably not even at
least the first if you're filming it you
kind of want to get caught right no look
so I guess they were sharing it on
various websites like ha haa and it's
kind of
insane look guys can I just jump the
shark right now and say Civil War just
because because I'm like if we're at the
point where staffers of the Senate care
so little about this country they treat
our government buildings like like porn
sets that's I just don't see anyone
having enough confidence in this
government to maintain it I don't think
that that necessarily sexual debauchery
is enough to claim like you know
conflict but because I was actually
talking to Ashley Sinclair about
yesterday she used to work down there
she's like it's just it's just non-stop
like debauchery I but you know what I
think that your philosophical angle is
right here Tim what it what it shows is
the lack of respect the lack of concern
the lack of care the overall clown show
that it really is there's no reverence
right I mean it's the same thing with
Jill Biden's Christmas video there's no
class there's no reverence it's just a
clown show it's just let's just clown
show this up we don't care about the
country we don't respect the country we
don't rever the country we don't Revere
these buildings I I mean I typically
would kind of stand where you are in and
in fact I I would say even after my
prison sentence I'm even more for prison
reform and Justice Reform empty the
prisons at this point uh but I
understand where you're going
philosophically I wouldn't be surprised
though if with the aftermath of this we
don't start to see more videos start to
surface yeah um I I have a different
take I I kind of don't care with these
guys screwing each other because the
government screws us every single day
right uh you seriously you look you look
at the surveillance secret FBI fisa
bills that they just passed you look at
the ndaa you look at the funding that
they're probably going to be giving
Israel and Ukraine very soon as of
course the average American is being
fleeced and destroyed financially I
don't care what these two dudes did this
is not a place to be respected this is a
place that has been hijacked by
sociopathic corporatists and globalists
that are using it as a machine to screw
over their American people and you're
the one getting familyfriendly show here
um but you that stuff's been going on
and the only reason these two guys are
willing to do this is because they don't
take our government seriously why for
everything you for every reason you
explained people are these guys are like
oh this government's a joke they rip
people off they blow kidss up nobody
takes it seriously then they go off on
the Senate hearing floor and they you
just made a meme you've just made a meme
put the guy who's facing away and you
put the American taxer and then the
person
doing my team my team you're watching
get on it get on it that's it though but
that really is making a t-shirt on the
best political shirts.com that is a
better that is a much more offensive
thing that is a much more offensive
thing oh you don't want fisa oh you
don't want funding for Ukraine well
we'll just go aead and slip it into ndaa
and you're going to get it anyway I got
to be honest it's actually um the most
disgusting meme gift ever in that in a
government building Democrat staffers
did this because now you can put any
group you can put FBI on the guy and and
j6 on the other guy there's a reason
there's a sex position called the
taxpayer okay all right they were
utilizing it you've just hit the
infinity meme Stone seriously the
shirt's coming soon uh meme infinity
stone yeah you could put Joe Biden on
one guy and US economy on the other guy
oh
yeah on post that on my time here
we go it's everywhere here we go please
man cuz sure make sure you TW this in
Eric July now no no but just set the Wes
I know
right go out of way I just set myself up
no no but on a serious note no I think
it's more so representative of like the
the institution right like even when
this whole j6 uh thing happened you know
I don't pretend like the Congress isn't
like a band full of criminals and and I
get it you know we we people we have
this idealistic way of looking at
government and it's supposed to they're
sacred and uh their buildings are are
something that is supposed to be
cherished and respected but I don't see
them that way you know I I haven't seen
them that way for a very long time but I
think this is more to your point
representative of the fact that it
absolutely is a clown show but I think
people seeing it that way and taking it
for what it actually is I don't
necessarily see that as a negative
negative thing I do believe that more
people should look at the senate or the
house and Congress just in general uh
with with more contemp when you really
truly understand the type of things it
is that they are absolutely doing so
they 100% are a band full of criminals
which is why I'm not I'm not at all
tripping off
of good thing that people will see this
then that's the that I see it I mean if
if if you look at it and you like and
you're like look this is a joke this is
a joke of an institution it is I would
agree with you it absolutely 100% is a
joke of an institution it's a it's a
place where people try to weaponize
things um and the and the power it is
that they have against their political
enemies it's not anything to be taken
seriously um like that at all so yeah
while you know to your point it's
probably all sorts of weird stuff that
does happen there dayto day that we
don't ever see it probably is a bunch of
debauchery and degeneracy um uh in there
anyway yeah hey first point it was that
Eric D July correct got it second point
I clarify I just wanted to clarify for
the record second point I wanted to make
here this is nothing new look at what
they do at the Bohemian Grove there's
literal secret societies there's
literally a brino brich there's literal
like parties and secret things that they
do that we can't even mention here on
this friend familyfriendly broadcast
there's an island that they bring
children to so for me
uh Hunter Biden and this latest
Revelation is the least offensive thing
that is happening in Washington D what's
Jeffrey tubin or these guys I mean tubin
tubin has the meme magic with his name
already in there but but I don't think
you can even compare you can what the
Epstein story way bigger of of a real
issue that that I think we should be
outraged about we should be showing
videos of Bill Clinton getting on the
lito express we should be showing uh
Bill Gates and all these other
individuals connected going to to that
private island that should be the big
controversy everyone in this room has
done more jail time than any of
Epstein's clients exactly wow that's
actually pretty crazy wait hold on hold
on uh Ian have you ever been in jail
negative oh okay all right well Eric
have you ever
been obviously you were you were just
there I was kind of making the joke like
I was probably the only one but it would
still it would still equate to it long
longest I've been in jail was like was
like 14 hours or something uh Luke I
know for sure and then you know so I
think Ian's the only one here the
gruesomely straight edge character
say Joe Biden lost the 2020 election did
he just say it we'll put we'll get G me
a free me a free saying you can join us
you can join us on the other side it's a
right of passage I it's a right of pass
Donald Trump won in 2020 and they're
going to come get you I mean they they
know where you live Tim we know that
that me I I uh uh I I just went because
I was they locked me up for
skateboarding for like overnight Luke I
remember that were you were you were in
Europe or something there was like eight
times yeah seven excuse me seven times
but it was it was like it was all
regarding my journalism I I I like grew
up really straight edge like follow the
rules follow order like my dad was in
the fire department have to do with
anything was in the fire department too
and then like but later I started to
learn like the appreciation of like if
if evil laws are passed like what the
Nazis did you kind of like Jeff Thomas
Jefferson would say you kind of have a
right to like ignore those laws or like
if if if a government becomes evil
you're supposed to be like well okay law
isn't everything you actually the
Constitution if you read the
Constitution it says if if the lawmakers
get out of control you actually have a
duty to get them out of government it's
actually a duty in the Constitution if
our government comes corrupted that we
have to do something about it but but
but Ian I I've never been convicted of
anything but I got arrested while I was
skateboarding they gave me some bogus
charge and then I spent half a day in
jail you've never had anything where you
wow look at that so not even detained
back of a cop oh yeah one time my buddy
had a joint in the car and he was
driving and the cops pulled us over like
a more than's cents
he's in it but so they got we got out of
the car we were only a block away from
my house like where do you live I was
like right there and they're like okay
get out of here I was just sleeping in
the back seats okay let me to clarify
the extent of Ian's uh incarceration is
a a car and his a friend with his car a
friend who was driving a car he was in
was stopped briefly and he was let go
and that is more time served than any of
Epstein's clients the hypothetically
yeah lit there's no way to know like
some of those clients might have been
dirty dirty criminals and we wouldn't
know but for for being let's say this
it's more than uh any of them have
served for the crime of being a client
of Epstein yes because that would be
zero as yeah exactly because maybe like
one of the clients beat a woman and got
arrested later on like I'm not saying
that you know what this story made me
think of when the two dudes getting it
on in the Senate is like uh the power
that one guy has to totally transform
the public conversation now like one guy
with a video camera can like bang
another guy and then everyone's talking
like 30 years ago you had to go through
NBC news like these videos couldn't even
get out anywhere unless someone at a
news organization was like well yes this
guy would go to NBC and say please air
this tape on your show they' be like no
we're not doing and they'd have to have
Polaroids they'd go or they maybe they
had a big handicam that wouldn't fit on
the guy's head so they'd have to have a
third guy taken the video are you saying
that Joe Biden put him up to this to get
all the negative press about Joe Biden
out of the
media wow that's an interesting concept
like uh to to kind of be like hey what
Hunter is doing well there's other
people that also do this no it's not
just that I got to be honest I if if if
it came out I'm not saying that this is
true I'm saying if the news came out
that this guy was put up to it as it I'd
believe it I'd be like oh wow like
they're like oh the Democrat
Administration knew a ton of press was
coming up Hunter Biden he divided
subpoena Joe Biden was defending him and
you know all these hookers $800 and
something thousand now I think the
number is in in prostitutes uh let's get
a guy out there a lot of hookers it's
crazy right one really lucky one no I
just saw the headline it was yeah or one
really we know it's more than one
prostitutes are a big part of Washington
DC uh there's a New York Post story
detailing how they're shipped into the
Bohemian Grove male prostitutes
specifically and there's also a very
famous story from the bush years where
George W bush got caught sneaking in a
gay porn star into the white house uh
that was another major Saga and Scandal
that kind of got swept under the rug so
this is this is this is now what we're
seeing finally happening but happens all
the time it's only outrageous because we
have video of it I think late stage
Empire Roman Empire they said part of a
late stage Empire is sexual Deery oh yep
did this video break because of Twitter
or x i I think the Daily Caller broke it
the daily call got the exclusive but all
of a sudden everyone's X timeline is
just flood that's where I saw it on X
you see the video it was not censored
when it came across man I'm like trying
to avoid it I'm leaving through
it now it's over know man it's I'm not
even going to bother to try to look at
my timeline now cuz I know it's going to
that's why Twitter is so important
though not so you can watch this
debauchery but maybe if it this is the
kind of stuff they can censor and hide
for the people they want to protect y
but thank goodness Elon Musk is at least
allowing I would say 95% free speech on
his platform yeah I air on the side of
allowing it although it is it is it can
like wreck your brain to see it you
think it should have been censored or at
least blacked out in like a black box
like click here if you want to see itens
pry sure they'll do that I'm pretty sure
they're going to do that because it just
takes time for the algorithm to kick in
and then catch this stuff but my my my
position has been if if Elon Musk allows
13y olds in the platform then all porn
must be banned oh I agree porn should
not be on X it's every this even news
worthy videos of like this should not be
allowed if they are young it should be I
mean YouTube does this and and sometimes
they get it wrong and that sucks but I
respect it they will age lock a video
and then people complain being like why
is my video being age restricted oh it's
not fair and sometimes it's not fair but
the challenge is how do you allow people
to upload whatever they want while
preventing people from uploading things
that are illegal so what you so what
YouTube does with the age restriction
stuff is if someone posts this video of
these staffers on YouTube yeah it should
be age restricted now here's the problem
kids just lie they just sign up and
claim to be 18 we should not allow
people to to give these materials to
kids I'm sorry it's just like you
couldn't do it on TV I don't understand
how it became normal to be like you know
we were talking to um I think I was
talking to stepen Marsh the guy wrote
the Civil War book and he's like oh
these kids can get it on the internet so
who cares just let them get these books
in school anyway and I'm like they
should not get it on the internet either
yeah that's but but the mentality of
many liberals is because of the internet
we should just give kids these books and
I'm like no yeah I had a friend that
would be like if you're going to be late
dude who cares just be as late as you
you're already late just be an hour late
like that's not how it works dude if I'm
5 minutes late that's way less worse
than being an hour late it's same with
porn on the Internet like as little as
possible and I feel like that's like the
bottom of the hill argument like oh
they're going to find it anyway so let's
put it in the classroom like what oh
you're going to you're going to die
anyway so I'm just going to stab you now
it's just like it doesn't even make any
sense but don't you think I mean I think
I mean I do think Twitter should do
every CU cuz YouTube I don't think you
can find any adult or pornographic
content on YouTube yeah you can oh yeah
you can it's not that good either
there's a congressional there's a very
similar video to the Congressional video
that that's going viral right now on
social media that's up on YouTube that
is standing behind and argued that it is
what was it artistic work but it's a
familyfriendly show here I thought that
was the twitch platform it it was a dude
guessing what's being um H there's ways
around that yeah I would say they how
how do I even describe this I don't want
to get trouble with your eyes just look
at the camera and they'll know see I
like that I think that's a fair argument
I forget who who it might have even come
across in a courtroom is they were
debating you know what's pornography or
what's like artistic content and someone
said when I see it I know the judge said
you know it when you see it yeah and I
think you know it's a little open-ended
but I would say if if the same effort
they put into Twitter Banning
conservatives or Banning Alex Jones or
myself or others if they put that same
effort into stopping the pornographic
content I would I would think they could
at least limit it I had uh I on
Wednesday I they use AI now and I
interviewed Dicky Barrett the video got
demonetized right I was like we didn't
even say because his name was it must I
um oh really I went to the monetization
I was like well I request a human review
and they immediately overturned it they
were like yeah it's fine it's but the
word Dicky caught the ai's attention cuz
oh wow so that's it's a little
heavy-handed but it's better than I
guess no moderation well so like the
issue is when they use it for political
sensorship not cool but if someone's
trying to put up videos of these
staffers you know doing a deed we don't
want kids finding that stuff so there's
got to be some way to deal with this I'm
sorry I don't know and there's a lot of
people the more Libertarians don't like
it they're like oh Tim's for censorship
and this is going to lead to a whole
bunch of problems I'm like bro I don't I
don't believe that because a technology
got invented we all of a sudden throw
out the rules where we're like kids
aren't allowed to be you can't solicit
adult materials to children like you
can't do it just because the internet
got invented doesn't mean you can do it
now you know so how do you find the
balance because when I was watching when
the video popped up on my timeline I
mean you can't really see much I mean if
you're an adult you know what you're
looking at and I obviously wouldn't like
that to be I wouldn't what my kids see
well see I must not have seen the whole
video I mean I didn't watch it I I I saw
it and I was like oh okay know fil is
like looking around and like oh really
okay well I didn't go I didn't go that
deep into it no pun intended no pun in
for I did I watched it for the people
for the team so that I could report back
newsworthy though I mean that's the
thing like that is a news story and you
were doing I mean you're doing you're
doing show prep I gotta be honest man
like I've watched videos of people being
shot and murdered and killed I watched a
video of a guy getting struck by
lightning twice Phil leonti posted that
I've watched videos of people being hit
by trains like if I'm going to try and
understand what's going on and there's a
news story and it's relevant I'm
watching the video but did you watch it
on Twitter the video yeah I think I
watched it on The Daily Caller okay cuz
I'm saying how are you going to watch
that's tough because I feel like maybe
you kind of just let it go for a little
period of time just so people can see it
and then you say okay we got to make
sure this doesn't go up because it is a
newsworthy story and I mean people
people want to know that this is what
your people in government are doing yeah
but I see what your point like if it
happens again tomorrow is that one
newsworthy too do we need to look at
that one as well and then the day after
are we supposed to look at that one too
and like what are we looking at now
people are making tons of memes of this
video there we go oh yeah that's what
I'm talking about I think the answer
that what they're looking at is AI
they're going to use artificial
intelligence to to try and preempt it
and and censor it before it gets out but
the problem with that is like then are
elbows too sexual like where does the
line get drawn is with whoever's in
power writing the code of the AI is
someone showing someone neck skin is
that too sexual cleavage you know a
round butt with pants on like cankles
yeah exactly how how
for I think one of the issues is when it
comes to this level of censorship the
issue is always if x is allowed then y
must be allowed too instead of if x is
allowed have we considered it should not
be for example uh they're do like right
now this is big thing where people will
like they'll print out mail nipples
women will print out a picture of male
nipples and then stick them to their
nipples and then post a topless photo
and be like male nipp nipples are
alloted on Instagram but females aren't
so we're just showing male nipples and
you can't really tell them they're like
aha the argument they're making is well
then it should be allowed for all women
to go completely topless on social media
instead of being like okay dudes can't
dudes got to wear shirts too see but now
we're getting into this this this level
of we're just not behaving like adults
right I mean there needs to be some
level of an adult conversation here it's
like yeah we know what you're doing
that's funny you're not going to do it
not like oh I found the loophole give me
a break what do you guys think about the
free the nipple campaign are you
familiar with it is that when the ladies
run around naked basically topless New
York City and because it used to be the
guys had to wear shirts in public until
like the 1920s guys got to wear shirts
they had to get the right legally to be
able to go topless in public and now
totally normalized instead of saying
women should be able to be topless too
how about we go the see this what I'm
talking about women are saying men can
wear not wear shirts therefore women
should be allowed to do it as well how
about we go we do the inverse and say
women aren't allowed to wear shirt
aren't allowed to be topless then men
shouldn't be allowed either why not say
no okay everybody got to wear a shirt
nobody topless anymore how come it
always goes in the One Direction of
closer and closer to
debauchery well I think it's obvious why
women can't walk around topless and men
can I mean yeah there'll be car
accidents that's what I'm saying see
this is like we're all adults here I
wouldn't be able to get anything done
we're all adults here we know why women
and you know the the mamory gland is a
little more distracting than the uh the
male chesticles and so I don't think
this is just but it gets into petty
stuff it's like oh well if the man can
do it then why can't the woman you know
why the woman can't it's a it's a
different body it's a different body
part it's a different sexual arousal
yeah we're more than just brains humans
are more than just brains we can't just
logic our way through in in Most states
it is legal for women to be topless I
mean I would say as a as a as a very
heterosexual man the concept of women
walking around topless sounds great but
then you see these monsters you see
these whales that are engaging in the
free the campaign shut it down so what
happens in New York is yes I'm
discriminating there there are morbidly
obese women who do it and and police
officers are like ma'am you need to
cover up and they go no I don't and then
when they get cited or charged they'll
sue the city and instantly win really
yeah they win of course of course it is
it it is it is sex-based discrimination
to say that women can't be topless if a
man can and so my argument is no no no
it's it's real simple just tell the guys
they got to wear shirts too but also
bikini bottoms like those really really
like g string bathing suit bottoms like
it doesn't you don't Brazilian Brazilian
bikini it leaves nothing to the
imagination it's just like they're
basically walking around naked yeah but
because there's a piece of thread in the
butt it's not even now they now they
have these like pieces of plastic that
are moldable that women just click like
you know what I mean there's not even
straps and it's just like okay we get
the future is going to be people put
duct tape on their junk and that's
it duct tape on it nudity is different
than sex that's for sure like nudity is
a very different thing let's let's flip
back over to the government is corrupt
part instead of the debauchery part
because we have this story from the
Daily Mail Rudy Giuliani has to pay
Georgia election workers
$148 million for accusing them of
helping steal the 2020 race America's
mayor faces Financial ruin over huge
damages and defamation case like how is
$148 million reasonable they're saying
it's 75 imp punitive damages 20 uh each
for emotional distress 16 for Freeman 17
for Moss for damage to their reputations
you kidding me man I get defamed every
single day and I can't get a single
penny out of these you ever heard of any
of these people by the way of course not
you know this is this is sadly how this
goes and and Giuliani is not going to be
the last person and I talked to some of
Trump's lawyers about this too because
people they don't seem to understand the
true nature of the political world that
we exist in until they reach certain
levels right and so when they came after
Infowars for censorship and I mean what
was the number they hit Alex with like
oh we're suing Alex for $3 trillion the
GDP of France 1.6 billion or something
no no no they wanted the GDP of France
it was a trillion dollars and they had
some formula that they worked this up
but my my point is this and I told was
three trillion I told some of this to
Trump's lawyers because they don't seem
to get it and they're like oh well this
is great that we get to go to court now
because now we're going to get to show
the evidence and prove our case uh no
you're not the the judge is going to
shut you down not let you show any
evidence and just rule against you and
they say well that's not how the legal
system works okay fine find out the hard
way for yourself and now Trump's lawyers
are fing that they think we're going to
present all this evidence to the court
and now they're like nope you can't
present any of that evidence say what
the heck3 trillion were the penalties
that Jones was facing that is more than
the GDP of France so my point is that
this is it's it's rare air or it used to
be rare air for you to get these rulings
and these court cases against you it's
going to become ever more present now
just like with censorship they test it
on one person and then they go after
everybody else Rudy Giuliani will not be
the last person that gets hundred
million judgments against him other
Trump attorneys will get it other Trump
Associates will get it and they're just
never going to stop the the justice
system is completely out of control I I
don't think people have really they
haven't grasped just how corrupted and
out of control it is and unfortunately
it's going to have to hit them just like
with Trump's lawyers oh present the
evence it will and it will it absolutely
will because I've been saying this for a
long time there there are so many people
who think if I just turn my lights off
and hide under the covers the angry mob
that's going door too smashing
everything will skip over my house no it
won't so here's a guy sitting in front
of me Owen who yelled some things on a
bullhorn and they try and they literally
use that in s sentencing documents the
speech you made tell them my dirty
speech Tim tell them my dirty speech
well it was not just what you said on on
the on the on the on the grounds it was
what you said later on on your show and
before too and before that had nothing
to do with what happened that day and I
believe correct me if I'm wrong you guys
had a permit for the protest yeah we
pered rally we had a stage that was um
back behind I think it was on the
northeast side of the capital we had a
stage set up we were going to be
speaking I was one of the speakers they
were other big speakers they were going
to be a part of that and and we were
going from the Ellipsis from Trump's
speech to our speaking stage that was
our route and when we saw all the chaos
at the capital we said hey we got to
stop this so we got on Horns to try to
stop it that's all on video we talked to
the Capitol Police and said hey what can
we do we want to work with you to try to
stop this that's all on video as well
the government even acknowledges this in
their sentencing memo against me that I
didn't go in and that I did try to stop
it and I did say we were there to be
peaceful but the higher up said no
you're still going to make an example
out of Shroyer but you know I I think we
can we can get into my personal case Tim
if we want but here's here's the larger
picture that that needs to be understood
and this goes beyond just the realm of
the political world
there is no incentive for justice in our
justice system whatsoever the incentive
from the US attorneys and the
prosecuting attorneys is convictions
that's their incentive they overcharge
you drastically hoping or assuming
they're going to get a plea out of you
which most of the time they do so they
keep their conviction rates High 98 99
100% so they think they can get a better
job climb the ladder their incentive is
convictions not Justice then you have
the bench the judge their incentive is
imprisonment got to fill the prisons got
to prove you're going to put the bad
guys away Justice never comes into the
frame here Justice is never even
entering into the conversation and let
me tell you from from somebody who's
been there there's there's three tables
here there's the judge's bench there's
the prosecuting attorney and then
there's you and until you've sat in that
corner and you've witnessed this be done
to you and you've sat there and watch a
judge and a prosecuting attorney sit
there and never even consider Justice
the feel
of of loneliness and isolation when you
realize there is no justice here Justice
was never the concern the concern from
the attorneys was conviction and the
concern from the judge was imprisonment
you never had a shot there is no justice
in the justice system anymore I don't
know what can be done about this I I
really I mean something has to change
the first thing we need to consider is
Donald Trump being elected next year and
then we'll see how things go when did
things change in the justice system
system are you guys familiar with change
like when did it become pretty corrupt
for a very long been like that forever I
mean I don't think probably all whole
Liv 100% like that's been what it is I
think it's just more blatant in that you
know look the left plays to win I may I
make this point all the time and this is
I think why they're able to get the dubs
it is that they're able to get because
they rely upon the people on the other
side even if it's like whether they're
Center or the right or whatever it is
that you want to call them where you
still kind of have some sort of belief
some sort of there's some sanctity in
sort of these institutions whether it be
from the police officers on all up to
the prosecutions like this is the way we
do thing and at the end of the day um Ms
will prevail um justice will prevail and
that's just not that to be fair has
never been the reality obviously you
being in in the situation it is that you
you been you've seen it sort of
firsthand it's like nobody's coming to
save me and all of these guys are
against me like it the system is is
literally rigged against you and
especially when you're dealing with
immoral people that have absolutely no
problem with weaponizing that
institution against you it's a soulless
thing like they're soulless it's a it's
a very difficult like enemy to to fight
I always use this analogy people that
watch me know I use this all the time
it's like you're going into a boxing
ring right and you're entering it in and
that the person on the opposite side of
you that you're supposed to be fighting
1 V one has already told you look my
gloves are loaded I've bought off the
judges I bought off the and I'm about to
cheat and what the Instinct of the
non-leftists is to still go into it with
fairness because we look at it like well
this is this is how we're supposed to
act we don't want to be like the enemy
the problem is is that the enemy has no
problem kicking you in in in the you
know midsection they have no issues with
doing that so that's a harsh reality
that we all kind of have to have to face
but I think once more people realize
that we can actually start to come up
with some sort of solution and some sort
of plan attack of attack but people need
to realize that this is how the justice
system is aligned this is the way that
it is sort of rigged um against you from
the prosecution on up and on on down
it's not there to serve Justice it's not
there to sort of reach some sort of
conclusion that is supposed to be the
the just one that's not the way that it
is designed well this is why I think Viv
Ramis Swami's campaign is actually the
most important campaign right now even
more so than Donald Trump's because you
know the right-wing has always had this
weird and it and it kind of deals with
they want to support law enforcement but
supporting law enforcement or police and
wanting Justice uh you know reform
justice system reform and prison reform
need to be two completely separate
issues they need to be two completely
separate issues and conservatives need
to get this and that's why VI Ramis
Swami really going hard against the
federal establishment is so important
because this is a winning issue and what
conservatives need to realize is that
Justice Reform is a winning issue you
will win I mean I don't want to get too
politically wonky here but it's an issue
that they've let the left dominate
they've let the Democrats dominate for
so long and and it's time for them to
get in there and Viv I think presents it
really well and and I mean I still
suspect Donald Trump gets the nomination
if he wins I hope he makes V in charge
of some special committee or something
to just completely abolish like 95% of
these Federal institutions that are so
corrupted conservatives and Republican
politicians need to stop being afraid of
their own shadow there you you know
you're the side of law enforcement
that's fine but Justice Reform and
prison reform are completely separate
issues and it's a winning issue you will
win a lot of votes if you can properly
verbalize and vocalize how you will
attack these issues I think like Vive
Gramma Swami has done what kind of
prison reform do you suggest well I'll
put it to you like this cuz it's very
complex and I could go on forever based
of off what I've learned from the top to
the bottom here but I'll try to put it
simply when I was in prison the Bureau
of Prisons had a hearing in front of
Congress where my name got brought up by
by Matt Gates thank goodness and they
were asking for $2 billion so they want
two billion more dollars because they
have staff problems and they have
infrastructure problems and believe me
they do uh I'm showering in showers that
have black mold in them I'm dealing with
staff in the prisons that I mean they Lo
they lost like $2,000 worth of my
property I mean I can go on and on and
on so the issues are real but we all
know if they put 2,000 excuse me $2
billion more into the Bureau of Prisons
do you think that's going to improve a
damn thing no it's not going to improve
a damn thing so what needs to be done if
they need2 billion more dollars annually
what they need to do is a little math
find out what annually how many
prisoners annually equals to $2 billion
and release them all Tomorrow release
every single one of them all tomorrow
there should not be a single nonviolent
criminal in prison that's our problem
here and maybe that's kind of the
springboard for the political argument
if if if if any Republican has the
courage to do it like V the springboards
needs to be no no non-violent criminals
belong in jail I mean really you have
here sure you can have House rest you
can have the ankle monitor I mean I
would say it like this cuz people always
ask well what is it like in there what
is it like in there we'll do a little
Camala Harris Vin diagram I would say
take a VIN diagram three circles you've
got um a daycare center right here
you've got an old folks home right here
and then you got a concentration camp
right here and then all the things that
they have in similar boom that's that's
what the federal system is like most I
mean most nights there it's just a bunch
of it's just a bunch of old men watching
TV I mean that's it that's it they're
just sitting around watching TV a lot of
these guys have kids they're fathers and
they're never going to see their kids
again and they're just sitting around
watching TV wasting their time way they
could be doing that so it's it's really
a dramatic issue that until you've seen
it firsthand it it's really hard to
understand but I've seen it firsthand $2
billion worth of prison release him from
the jail tomorrow there's your $2
billion that I mean we have more
prisoners here than we do in China and
and Russia it it's also important to
know that what you were well I don't
know if I don't know if China's numbers
are really uh
docent good point they also disappear
and they you know they're never found
again and there's a lot of organ there's
a lot of organs also found there that
are readily available but that's a
different story but but good point I I
definitely agree with you but you
brought up a kind of a an anarchistic
libertarian perspective no victim no
crime a lot of people on the right are
saying we got to back to Blue no matter
what we got to back the police officers
the police officer saying I don't care
what laws they're going to make up I'm
going to enforce them to the fullest
extent that I can happily and we've seen
a huge transition from from actual
criminals going to jail to now political
thought criminals going to jail which is
absolutely crazy it needs to be
addressed in a way because you you you
kind of described it as soulless there
is a lot of soullessness there is a lot
of people who are just like I'm just
doing my job there are a lot of Cala
harrises that believe that they have to
make their way up have to of course make
their career by putting innocent people
behind bars which she did extensively
especially when it came to things like
marijuana which is absolutely freaking
ridiculous so yeah I I agree with you on
those larger kind of libertarian
sentiments I think they would help
ganize the base and I think the people
who are rooting for back the blue are
essentially rooting for their own
enslavement and imprisonment and maybe
the selling point to conservatives or
Republicans that that are too afraid to
do that say well I'll tell you what if
you don't if you don't have Criminal
Justice Reform or prison reform well
then you're going to end up in prison
very soon so there's a difference
between victimless crime and nonviolent
crime like um like Financial crimes like
what Sam bakman freed is allegedly done
or maybe he's been convicted of it so
like do you also encourage like you said
nonviolent like like high level um
Financial criminals do you think they
should be let out to is there a victim
so nothing is there would be in that
case hold on I I believe the purpose of
prison for the most part is to take
someone who is dangerous and make sure
they can't hurt people so for for SBF
the real uh P penalty should be house
arrest with restrictions meaning you
can't do Financial work you can't you
can't trade on these platforms you are
being removed from the area which and
where you did these crimes You could
argue that stealing a bunch of people's
money makes it so they can't buy food
and then they starve to death which is
like a violent act but the point is this
did this guy go around like mercilessly
beating children
there's like there's the overt attack
violence but then there's also the
stealing the resource irrelevant but but
jail is supposed to rehabilitate people
it doesn't do any of that it makes them
worse there's two philosophies in in the
prison system there's Rehabilitation or
punishment right retribution but but see
I think where you're going nothing is
black and white right obviously nothing
is black and white and I think Tim you
know you propose a good idea like if you
if you go into a smash and grab that's a
violent crime if you steal if you steal
from somebody and that takes food off
their table You could argue that that's
a violent crime Financial crimes like
SPF I think that you could reasonably
argue okay you're going to be maybe on
house arrest but more importantly every
Financial activity that you make is now
going to be monitored I mean it's not
that hard to do here's what I'd say SBF
there is zero risk of him punching a kid
in the face so we don't have to worry
about locking him up behind multiple
razor wire fences cuz he's not in he all
we have to worry about is we don't want
this guy doing Financial deals and
trading because that's where he broke
the law in fact I don't even know what
house arrest does I would say house
arrest because we do want some punitive
element of this short duration maybe a
couple years and then after that it's
restrictions on access to financial
systems and services he should be able
to live and work but he's going to be
breaking rocks or working at a grocery
store he's not going to be doing big
deals now if a guy robbed a liquor store
this guy is dangerous armed robbery okay
we remove this guy from society
temporarily and tell them you are a
danger to people so we're putting you in
a box if if someone is not if there is
no victim or if it's non-violent then
you're then we do not need prison so uh
victimless crimes means like somebody
was found with pot I I don't see how
locking that person up in prison solves
any problem I agree on the victimless
crimes that people can be better served
by learning I mean what would be a
better what do you think for like
someone caught with a bunch of pot
nothing the War on Drugs the War on
Drugs needs to end tomorrow uh the cop
can say oh pardon me sir I I wasted your
time yeah if you're going to go after
the pot dealers you got to go after big
Pharma right well see but see now now
this is an important Point what I
learned being in there I'm not the only
political prisoner in there now in the
political sphere of media
yes people that get arrested for dealing
drugs in my opinion are political
prisoners if they worked for a pharmacy
or if they worked for a big
pharmaceutical company you can you can
deal drugs all freaking day long and you
can make billions of dollars doesn't
matter how many people
die yeah but if you deal fitel you're
going to jail forever now I'm not
endorsing this is no way shape or form
an endorsement of drug use it's bad for
you
but those are political prisoners in my
eyes too guys it's Friday so I
absolutely have to pull up this story
and segue to it uh I'm I is this is this
real Donald Trump was giving a speech
and I'm seeing these images pop up
everywhere he says everything is bad
under Biden even the lemonade is killing
people did you see that people drink the
lemonade and die the lemonade didn't
kill you when I was President it was
tasty and fun to drink we loved the
lemonade didn't we this sounds like a
deep F we did but not under Biden bacon
is more money gas is more money the
lemonade is more money and it kills you
when life hands you lemons Joe Biden
kills you with them Tim but Tim know Tim
we need a little context here Tim
because we all went to the Biden rally
and we drank the lemonade I don't think
it was lemonade okay I think it came
from Hunter Biden we ran a little
analysis on it lot of cocaine okay there
was a lot of cocaine maybe a little
parmesan cheese I don't think they're
selling it lemonade anymore okay I think
it's a little bit something else it
might have killed somebody with a little
fenel in there okay there's got to be I
I I I can't believe it's real but I can
believe it's real and the issue is we
find the video Panera had lemonade right
yeah everyone's talking about the huge
when life you lemons Joe Bon kills you
with what is the story I'm going to try
that lemonade there's a bunch of stories
uh Panera's lemonade that kills you is
really a story about our broken country
lemonade with like 500 Miga bread faces
suit from family of student who died
after drinking charged lemonade Panera
family sues Panera Bread after a college
student who drank charged lemonade
dies caffeine lemonade they have like
160 uh what is it it's 400 milligram in
the large
sizea a lot and iink I drink coffee
that's a lot of C it's more than coffee
moreu is it like a cup of coffee like 40
yeah and like a 10 cups of coffee in one
glass and people probably drank like two
of them real put on like those Energy
Drinks like you don't consume more than
two in 24 hours or whatever says more
than a can of Red Bull and Monster
combined plus the 30 you know to drink
Celsius they they're 200 milligram plus
30 teaspoons of sugar 30 teaspoons of
sugar that's probably what's going to
what's going to K you I mean at some
point yeah the caffeine also spikes your
adrenals
that's the thing though like I I I mean
I would not suggest anybody do this
because it's obviously bad for you but
I'm I'm probably taking like 500
milligrams of caffeine a day but I I've
built a tolerance to it like my body is
ready for it you jump into that as a kid
you're it's four it's four so one
charged lemonade was four cups of coffee
yeah it's 390 390 milligram in a 30 o
serving but they allow refills so people
were literally having four five six of
them a day in one
like yeah this is lemonade this we even
know then do we even know did this girl
only have one or did she maybe have two
three or four this says she died after
drinking her name is Sarah Catz she was
21 Old year old college student with a
heart condition died after drinking a
Charged Lon I got bad news heart
condition from from a I got I gotad news
it's plant-based though I got bad news
there was another guy that also I got
bad news oh viral images of Donald Trump
talking about lemonade or fake yep
someone get ready for the the future
which is
fake but they were funny they were funny
I couldn't find the video but it was too
good to pass up when life hands you
lemon Joe Biden kills you with him
what's the is Panera still selling this
stuff they had to pull it okay it was
two wrongful death suits the other guyy
was 46y old he drank three glasses and
then I'd like to know if 12 cups of
coffee in one sitting I'd like to know
if they were uh if they were hit with a
little uh little Co juice there was more
than just caffeine if they took you know
uh look man I got I got to be honest you
drink 12 cups of coffee in like 40
minutes you're going to be in the
hospital yeah I've had I did that once
anecdotally and had like massive nerve
pain in my neck like pre-stroke nerve
pain I was like what is wrong and I just
stopped with the caffeine for a week
after that oh dude I was driving so this
is when I went on a road trip to the
North Dakota pipeline protest you guys
remember that one oh yeah and then I had
to drive from that protest to La so this
is North Dakota to Los Angeles and I had
like two days to do it so I was like I'm
not stopping and so I was awake for like
28 hours and I just kept slamming like
5H Hour Energy and it got to the point
like the weirdest I started
hallucinating like I'm I think that's
sleep deprivation and yes right but the
caffeine was keeping me awake and so I'm
driving in my car and like here's how I
describe it everything I could see I'm
like pulling up to a gas station it
looked
like what what is that thing where it's
3D but it's outlined like a cartoon you
know what I'm talking about rotoscope
not rotoscope so it's like it it's kind
of like rotoscope but it's uh they do so
uh they make like Borderlands Graphics
yeah yeah it's called Sal shaded C
shaded that everything was turning into
that and then there was like a weird
texture appearing over things and I'm
like I'm sitting in the car going like I
think I'm going to die my heart was
probably going like a like 120 beats per
minute or something and then I just
pulled over and I was like I'm going to
just drink water and then sit and so I I
had to stop I drank way too much it
doesn't make you less tired it binds to
The adenosin receptors adenosine and are
so you don't realize you're tired the
caffeine but you're still get really the
fatigue was still tripping you out
probably like you were saying I'm I'm
I'm probably I had 200 milligrams of
caffeine before I got here these drinks
are 150 a piece I've already had one so
I'm halfway through this so I'm at least
400 milligrams in right now did you do a
lot in the past have you always done a
lot of caffeine uh not really not until
I really got into my 30s and it was kind
of like a necessity to work as much as I
do more I think that's what happens with
people in coffee is they drink coffee
all the time I just don't like coffee so
what I'll do is um either find an
organic source of caffeine or take like
a caffeine tablet or resell energy
supplements at infow Wars 2 and I'll
drink that too um but again I'm not
telling people to to drink 500
milligrams of caffeine a day I'm saying
you got to like it took me a while to be
to the point where okay this is kind of
where I need to be where I can function
and do everything I need to do during
the day and and then still be able to
sleep I've got to cut it off at a
certain time otherwise I won't be able
to sleep so in other words probably not
sleeping tonight whenever whenever I'm
driving and I start to get tired I'm
falling asleep
the cars in front of me turn into cat
faces W I start hallucinating and like
the tail lights you know that feel
that's when I'm like I am pulling over
and I am done yeah yeah that's not the
acid no I don't do that stuff but like I
used to I US mean I used have to drive
at like 3:00 in the morning to the
airport for my job and I'd be super
tired I'd be driving and then all of a
sudden like I'm falling asleep but I
can't close my eyes the cars in front of
me just like start to turn into cats
yeah that's when you pull over and you
should try some uh you should try some
vitamin B uh a lot of the coffees now
especially at a lot of the major stores
Dunkin Donuts Starbucks they're
absolutely filled with some of the worst
additives and ingredients and Seed oils
you can ever ever have but I'm just
speaking to the average American out
there that is kind of hooked on it as of
course the ingredients in there are are
truly just absolutely awful and I I
really do believe that they have been
incrementally adding more and more high
fructose corn syrup to the point where
we become more and more addicted to it
and uh it it's one of the things ailing
our society more than I think cigarettes
more than anything else that that is
negative sugary drinks are the worst why
America is so fat yeah when you when you
cut sugar out 100% after like a week if
you taste sugar you'll go oh yeah it's
like pure syrup yeah it almost burns
like it's just too sweet so yeah like
everybody's noticed this if you uh if
you like eat a bowl of ice cream then
eat some piece of candy it doesn't taste
sweet because you've already just
slammed sugar in your mouth I would
argue if your bananas aren't sweet you
have too to much sugar in your system if
carrots aren't sweet you have too much
sugar in your system yeah carrots should
be sweet for you coconut water should be
sweet for you but I think it's important
to distinguish the difference between
processed sugar and natural sugar cuz
natural sugar is not nearly as bad for
you as processed sugar Su it could be
worse like refined sucrose is it it can
because of the concentrations that they
use that's pretty nasty but compared to
like aspirat tame and high fructos Sye
yes sweeteners these synthetic
sweeteners that they might call but for
some reason I don't know how they can
get away with don't take don't take
nutrition advice from me look it up fact
check me but my understanding is glucose
your body can utilize right away
fructose your body has to process in the
liver so the fructose is sugar that's
found in fruits it's very taxing on the
system the problem is we don't just have
glucose syrup anymore we do high
fructose corn syrup they literally take
corn syrup put an enzyme in it to
convert it into fructose so it tastes
sweeter and strains your liver and
causes damage I was looking at like the
it was dowo chemical I believe made was
making high fructose for a while and I
think it was Dow chem went to their
website and it took me like 20 30
minutes to dig through the website on
the process of how to make it and they
they put it in these big tanks and they
make it with like a and then between
creation of the fructose high fructose
corn St they'd have to wash the tanks
with a resin and it was like the
chemical uh I don't want to misspeak it
could have been arnik but the chemical
that they Ed to wash the tanks they
don't put on the list of the ingredient
of the high fructose but they put like
chemicals in the tank between production
to clean the tanks that are probably I
would guess ending up in the high
fructose corn syrup yeah just like
chemical runoff that's what a lot of the
the uh like canola oils and stuff no
they're absolutely horrible and uh you
know you think you're cutting out sugar
but you really have to cut out the
drinks like the drinks are the worst and
I was I was Bamboozled I was I was
convinced that the the green teas that I
was having I was like oh it's green tea
oh it's ginsing oh they're totally
griffy 50 grams of of high fruit to his
corn syrup and I was just chugging that
thing like it was nothing look at these
ones you're drinking yeah I'm not
drinking these are not as bad but yeah
they have a bunch of additives uh this
has 11 gr and that's added mate mate
that's added to this got this right here
spin drift it's got zero what's in it
what's it added sugar is it 11 on top of
something else no no they just add 11
that's not too much but I mean maybe I'm
just desensitized to the 40 or 50 that
you see in soda I got I got to tell you
guys 30 whatever I love I love Bubble
Tea anybody you got you got bubble tea
it's I can't drink it it's disgusting
it's like drinking maple syrup I have to
tell them no sugar just give me like the
the the tea mixture or whatever and then
put the bubbles in it the bubbles sugar
enough man I've had like maybe 24 grams
of sugar in the last four hours or maybe
maybe more but I can feel my nose
starting to run like that's I don't
normally I haven't been sick since I got
Co two years ago and like I a lot of
it's probably CU I don't need a lot of
the sugar is swelling and all that and
it's I can sense it I can feel it right
now let's go for this too let's go for
than thanks for letting us everyone know
let's uh let's go for this debate we got
going on from cnr.com $220,000 raised in
3 hours for legal defense of man who
decapitated satanic statue in Iowa
capital my conscience is held captive to
the word of God not to bureaucratic
degree and so I acted now hold on there
a minute we have this tweet from Matt
Walsh Matt Walsh of course threw down
the gauntlet and struck my face with a
dueling glove over my my opinions on Bud
Light No that's totally fine but he has
he has an opinion on this he says a
satanic altar has no right to exist
certainly not inside a government
building we are not bound by our
principles to sit by impotent while our
state houses are turned into platforms
for literal devil worship quite the
opposite in fact now yeah I I I don't
like devil worship and I think the way
you go about stopping something like
this is through procedure and policy and
not through barbarism and so I guess uh
the the the the issue here is Matt Walsh
is defending the idea that this guy
knocked toppled this altar to Satan and
Satanism it's not NE I don't know if
it's actually Satan it's like Satanism
the religion and and my attitude is like
dude I I don't see the argument in if
you feel emotionally satisfied with it
it was just because that's the argument
made by the left for taking Jeff Thomas
Jefferson down to be fair Matt Walsh
addresses this addresses this and says
obviously there's a difference between a
revered historical figure who founded
our you know components of our country
and of our government and Satan and I'm
I completely agree and it should be
considered a venerable object which is
legal a legal defin definition for stuff
like that I don't think it's Satan
Monument is a venerable object but the
issue I suppose is if we are a nation
that has a right no law respecting an
establishment of religion and people are
allowed to worship the way they want to
worship then we either say we do not
have religious iconography in state
houses or we have to accept that there's
going to be wacky religions we don't
like yeah to me I think that the the
former has to be a this is always the
issue with the whole public property uh
sort of concept it's like what do you
what do you allow versus what what it is
that you don't which is why believe
personally all that stuff needs to be um
um limited because you know to your
point Tim you start getting emotional uh
with it and people yeah obviously
there's a difference between Thomas
Jefferson and freaking Satan but you
know I still and you know to some people
unfortunately that let's say that's in
the eye of the of the beholder and so to
leave it up to for a dispute for any Joe
Blow to say hey when I'm feeling a
certain type of way I get to do this
versus when I don't you know that's
always going to be a problem which is
why I think the public public property
thing is is just a fundamental issue and
look I'm a realist at the end of the day
so I get it what Matt Walsh is kind of
uh uh where he's getting at you know
look man the game is not the we we were
talking about this in previous segments
Man the game is the game so um you know
when the left when they want to let's
say that they'll be and break the rules
uh to to to mean whatever it is that
they want to mean so they don't give a
crap about what it is that you um hold
tight and true to and whatever uh
monuments it is that you have if they
feel like it's worth them toppling it
they'll use whatever nonsensical laws
perhaps even to justify their own their
own sort of action so I think
fundamentally I get it you know what I
mean it's like hey I'm playing a game
that they plan you know this is this
this is why the American left or or more
historically speaking uh conquering
totalitarians destroy culture you see
this shouldn't even be a debate in
American culture I mean we can get into
the kind of nuance of oh well you would
allow in a government building versus
what you don't but if we had a culture
if we had a consistent culture this
wouldn't even be a debate we wouldn't we
wouldn't be talking about should a
Christian Monument stand or should a
historical monument stand that would be
our culture and we would agree that's
our culture whether we agree with it
spiritually that wouldn't even be up for
debate a satanic Monument shouldn't even
be in the debate but because they've
destroyed our culture and we've got all
this infighting now about oh what should
be here what should be there what's the
Nuance of all these laws well at at some
point culture kind of would overwhelm
all of that but because our culture has
been destroyed now we have to sit here
and have a debate of does a satanic
statue belong in the government building
it's like are you kidding me but but the
question is do you want to become what
you're fighting so I would just kind of
counter that that kind of point of view
if we're if if we're going to be doing
that okay let's let's you know isn't
that a winning issue like you can't
support the guy that tears down Satan
right right but no that that's again I
get it but in that's where I think the
left sort of differ from the quote
unquote American right because they
don't care about that part which is why
they're such a a difficult enemy to
fight so while yeah I don't want to be
you and I don't want to become you it's
not going to stop them from kicking me
in the nuts when they get when they get
a chance they have absolutely no issues
bastardizing whatever power it is that
they they they sort of have again like I
was saying before bending and breaking
the rules so you can go up to him and be
like look man I I don't want to be you
you like I look at you and you're the
worst of us all but in the same respects
on the other the other hand they're like
well I don't care I am I dirty yeah I I
I the left I mean you should have
everybody realized this in 2020 or at
least you should have um that should
have been a wakeup call for everybody
when the whole Co thing and the pro like
George Floyd stuff stuff happened when
the left literally the day before all
this the riots and and whatever took
place they were basically saying if you
went outside you were going to kill
grandma and then the next like out of
nowhere the George Floyd situation
happens now everybody's bunched up
together and we're walking the streets
and they didn't we knew they were
Hypocrites they didn't care that's the
thing and this is what I'm trying to
explain to the to to the to the right in
this country it's like look you are
dealing with an enemy that does not
abide by the same set of Ethics morals
whatever it is that you want to call
them that you that you have if anything
they will use it against you it's like
that it's like a militant like sort of
leftist atheist trying appeal to God
when they'll they'll you know say
whatever against God you know 10 minutes
before they made their claim or they'll
be like well that would be something
Jesus would do they do that stuff
because they're trying to weaponize your
own this is why the heads of those
universities when they were asked about
the calls for genocide of the Jews
immediately said well the Constitution
protects they they routinely defy the
principle of free speech our
constitutional protections and then the
moment someone questions some aborn
thing they want to say they immediately
run hide behind the Constitution other
words there is no Jenna Ellis of the
left saying hey guys are we sure we want
to do this I don't remember anyone any
lawyers from the left saying hey stop
tearing down Monument stop attacking
police officers they don't care no and
that's what I'm saying and I don't
really I'm not going to pretend like I
know all the answers this is what I'm
saying that's such a difficult enemy to
to to to combat right because again it's
like I'm going into it and I'm trying to
be ethical with this but I also have to
understand that you're not playing by
those same set of rules you'll hold me
to those standards if it means that it's
advant agous to you but at the end of
the day it's not anything that you're
going to follow do you think a lot of
that is denial though from the American
right cuz you say this is what I'm
trying to get the American right to
understand do you think a lot of it is
denial like oh we're not under attack
the Constitution isn't under threat like
there this isn't actually going on
delusion I think is more of the accurate
term to what it is it's like I get it
you want to believe that the world is
the way that it it's it's actually not
but for the sanctity of our or really
for our own sanity it's like we need
this to be true it's like what we talk
about uh with it with police officers
whether it be with the uh Judicial
System whatever it may be you like to
think that these people are better than
us they are the best of us they're not I
mean you can see all the examples in how
they're not if anything they're the
worst of us like I say with the Congress
really being a band full of absolute
criminals but in order for us to get by
in life it's it's comforting to believe
this idea that the world is something
that it's absolutely not and like I said
it's just such a it's such a difficult
enemy to to combat because they're just
not going to play fair and then they
tell you that they have no issues being
like yeah I was a hypocrite to what I
did what I said yesterday yeah I said we
said that you were going to kill Grandma
we told y'all hell we even arrested some
of y'all if it came down to it but now
we're going to link up and we're going
to uh protest and yeah it's okay in fact
they were using the Medical Institution
to try to justify what it was it is that
they were doing when they were linking
up despite them telling you that this
was something that was criminal when you
did it that shows that they just don't
care there were scientific articles
there was Mainline scientists and the
corporate media saying this is going to
help people this is going to be great
for going down because because all of
these people were marching together
despite them yesterday saying you were
killing Grandma it was uh I think like a
university in Colorado that was like we
found black lives matter protests
actually reduced the spread of Co
unel anti-lockdown protest made that
made Co worse and then there was video
out of New York where everybody's
marching and the doctors wearing masks
are all clapping cheing but then there's
a photo from DC where people are
protesting lockdowns and nurses were
blocking cars and looking angry these
people are hypocrites and they're insane
yes a combination of the two part of the
issues I got with the the santanic alter
thing that Matt Walsh is talking about
is that I think what started it all was
that someone came in and quote defaced
the what was it a in Congress somewhere
by putting up the Ten Commandments
technically because you're not supposed
to put up any religious text in that
building so they start someone started
it by putting up the Ten Commandments
now I don't necessarily agree with the
Ten Commandments and I find that Satan
is probably considerably more evil
relatively in general Society than the
Ten Commandments but it it it seems like
the satanic thing was like a response to
well you put up your religion I'm going
to put up my religion how do you like it
so I don't think maybe so so but in in
that regard though you have to ask then
is it even really a religion or is it
just
spite probably both technically I don't
know exactly what the what the impetus
was but I mean this this Temple of Satan
the satanic temple is now legally
religion since I don't know when last 20
years or couple years ago or something
couple years maybe like four no actually
like five or six years ago I think so
they're they're Tech they got tax code
certification or something could have
been anybody could have been an Islamic
symbol could have been a Scientology
thing they're doing it response to
having the Ten Commandments in in like
the building I guess do you think they
would have done the same thing if
somebody put Muslim scripture up there
like RI Muslim scripture would have not
have been ripped down oh yeah yeah I
don't think so somebody had a visal
response to the satanic imagery no no no
but I mean if the if the satanic imagery
was in response to the Ten Commandments
no no yeah yeah they wouldn't put
anything up over Muslim stuff yeah I
agree right I agree I I think it's I
think it's I think it's animous towards
Christianity is what I think could have
been yeah or could have just been
towards organized religion in general
who knows it's tough to say who I don't
know who did it who did it and who put
up the Ten Commandments did that ever
come out did both those people get in
trouble cuz why they let the that's my
point is I don't think it is against
organized religion in general cuz I
think we all agree if it was Muslim
literature or scripture they would not
have responded with thean it's just it's
an assumption I don't know it's tough to
say I have to ask the guy I don't
necessarily condone tearing it down but
it shouldn't have been there none of
those temples should none of those
things should have been there Ten
Commandments shouldn't have been there
and the I I definitely don't agree with
tearing it down you think it should have
stayed I think it should have been
removed through
procedure like you file a lawsuit and
well technically tearing it down is a
procedure you know right what I mean is
I'm not it's a BLM procedure what
they're trying to do is they're going to
go to normies and say look at what Matt
Walsh says when a guy destroys our
statue and then they pretend they care
about statues being removed they're
going to make a false equivalency now
mat is correct they're not the same
thing but I I think what he what what I
would say he's missing here is we're
trying to convince regular people we are
right they are playing this dirty game
where they hold their hand in front of
your face and saying I'm not touching
you I'm not touching you and then when
you swap their hand away they post a
video online saying guy punches peaceful
activist this is what they're doing
every step of the way Matt wall
uh his reaction is the desired outcome
they wanted someone to smash the satanic
alter they were hoping and praying
someone would do it well let me just
kind of Switch Lanes on this issue then
for this guy who I believe is running
for congress in Mississippi the guy that
uh smashed the satanic altar he is uh I
I believe so whatever whatever we think
about the the action that he had that
day I would say as a republican voter
and as as somebody who's looking for
somebody with a with a spine in the
Republican part in Congress I say good
that's the exact type of person I want
in Congress because they're not going to
take any crap and they're actually going
to do the things that Republican voters
have been wanting their conservative
representation to do forever so if it
was a political stunt I say smart move
good for him my concern is if it if it
inspires people to do it again and then
like I have something on my lawn and
someone comes up and they're like I
don't like it and they smash it down
that's not your lawn they're not going
to nobody's going to do it on your lawn
I mean I guess supposedly but this
wasn't a government building it was a
big story it was a viral story knew he
could seize the moment did you see the
guy like 5 days ago walk in with a fire
extinguisher and extinguish the
manora kind of similar no like he didn't
agree with the manura in some way that
that that was brutal and and awful and
wrong that like knocking on a satanic
altar irks me in a procedural kind of
way and like a strategic kind of way
like don't give them the thing to desire
actually going after a legit legitimate
religion which is literally just
lighting candles I'm like that's a dick
move you know what I mean polish is very
a very Christian Nation and he looked at
that as a Christian and he didn't like
that culture being in his his Christian
Nation that was that was how he looked
at it and I think regardless of of
whether it's Judaism or Satanism there
should be a calm re a high higher level
reasoned response not a brutal
animalistic response I I reject the the
the ethos and ideology of BLM and the
tactics of the left where they they
stomp around like morons biting and
punching things and I think that we
actually could be ideologically better
men and say here is exactly why this
should not be for my reason stands and
we say okay and we take it down and that
the message we send is that we deal with
things in an orderly fashion yeah I I
think this debate is very important
right now because I I I think we're
we're dealing with a situation where a
lot of the people within the doj and the
FBI want to provoke a certain situation
they want I I think the people on the
right to be angry they are acting in a
very litigious unfair way and with them
now going after journalists we were
talking about this a couple days ago
it's almost as if they're trying to
provoke the people on a right to
overreact so I I I think being calm I
think not overreacting I think being uh
better than the left and not acting
violent and not acting on our emotions
is our strength there are some key uh
key key things to it that that are
disadvantages but but there's also a lot
of advantages for it as well and I think
we should uh uh stay along those lines
in my own personal opinion I could be
wrong but that's just my initial kind of
knee-jerk reaction to Eric your logic is
kind of different right if I'm hearing
you correctly well yeah because I I look
at it both ways it's like a strategy
thing so while I understand that there
is obviously going to be instances where
it is important to not necessarily act
like let's say your opponent is going to
act I just think you have to be a little
more analytical than just like hey
you're the bad guy and you're acting in
a certain way and I don't want to be
that guy I think you have to be more
strategic with it it's like look in a in
a given instance where it is going to be
advantageous for you to act a certain
way long term you got to take the game
for what it is we can't be I think us
trying to be too idealistic about it is
how they cons how they got so much
ground because we looked at it like oh
we are we're the more analytical guys
right we uh uh we do things the right
way mean while the left kind of comes in
stomping around flipping tables doing
whatever the hell it is that they that
they want and to be fair it's worked for
them I mean they've gotten what it is
that they they they wanted so it's like
I believe there's an appropriate
response to where yeah you don't want to
just be a leftist I don't I don't think
any that that doesn't help uh anybody
but in the same respect you got to
understand what the actual game is and
as I always say act accordingly it
doesn't mean act like them it means do
not go into a game
that is unfair trying to play fair
because you're going to lose every
single time it's the difference between
dour law and deao Rule dour Rule and
this is a French term dour means by law
deao means by fact so you may own a a
property dour the law you have the
paperwork but if someone goes and sits
in that house and takes it and won't let
you in then they Own It by de facto You
by by fact you don't own it anymore but
and if all you do is just play the dour
game and you're like well I have the
paperwork therefore it's but 2 weeks 2
months 2 years go by and you can't get
into your house then you're you're
you're playing asymmetrical and it's a
sad it is sad that that is reality but
that is reality and it's it's reality in
war often unfortunately absolutely and
and we try and stick to the law it's
very important but when when you know
fact is whoever you know the fact is the
fact of what is but they don't care
about the law look what happened to to
Owen uh which which I think we should be
talking about your particular case more
because as you said now a lot of other
journalists are going to be arrested and
prosecuted because of what you went
through and and really it's not just the
journalists cuz there's no doubt they're
going to use this as a president to go
after other journalists but I also think
they want to Snuff out any right-wing
activism as well they don't just want to
Snuff out any any journalism that may go
against the establishment in this case
it's the leftwing establishment but they
also want to Snuff out any activism from
from conservatives as well and so I
think it's really a two-pronged issue
the journalism one is obviously the one
that gets the focus and and the one that
it has more more of the press at this
point but it's definitely at an activist
level as well I think the real reason
why the Democrat Party hates me so much
is they they couldn't imagine if there
were a hundred of me a thousand of me a
million of me they wouldn't exist they'd
be done they wouldn't be able to have
any of these Shams going on because when
the Democrats show up to the capital
what do they do they bring a thousand
people wearing the pink vagina hats they
bring a thousand people for a pro
Palestinian protest they bring a th
people to to chant against Amy con
Barrett or or Brett kavanau I was one
man I was one man that stood up against
the Trump impeachment sham it's not like
I'm the only one that knew it was a sham
it's not like I was the only one in that
room that knew it was the Sham but they
kind of see me as like the Spartacus
where oh if other people think they can
be Owen Shroyer if other people think
they can stand up and tell the Democrat
what for and why then well we got to
Snuff that out now we got to shut him
down now we can't have this Marcus
aurelus showing up in Washington DC they
tried to ban me from DC the Democrats
tried to ban me from DC entirely twice
and the judges laughed him out of the
room and it wasn't just about attacking
you I think it was also about scaring
everyone else in the industry who's
going to be like oh Owen's in jail for
saying something I better watch out what
I say now I better be careful now so I I
I truly truly do think your case is very
important to talk about are there any
updates that we should know about is
there any any other details that haven't
been released to the general public that
that you think are important to
highlight here well we are going to be
taking my appeal to the Supreme Court
that is where it's going to end up as
far as its fate there I think it's still
a little too far off or foggy to know
what the Fate there might be but you
know my case has recently gotten
attention because of my my prison
sentence obviously but the truth is I've
been politically persecuted by the
American left and the Democrat Party
since 2019 really since 2018 when they
censored me off of all the main stream
social media platforms they arrested me
for disrupting Congress which again this
is something that happens all the time
David hog disrupted Congress he stood up
during a hearing on gun violence and
disrupted Congress now is David Hall
going to get charged and go to jail no
of course not and I would argue he
shouldn't I don't think he should I
believe that's David Hog's First
Amendment right when all them show up
and they disrupt congress with for
whatever reason for abortion climate
change all this other stuff do they get
charged do they get arrested uh 98% of
the time no they don't the only time
they will is if they resist arrest or
assault a police officer then they'll
get arrested what normally happens in
that situation and this is what would
have happened to me they detain you they
escort you out of the building and then
they release you on your Merry way and
say you're not you're not welcome here
again today but somebody got on the
walkie talking for the Capitol Police
that December in 2019 and said oh no no
no no you're arresting Shroyer you're
charging him and arresting him and even
the capital police were like what the
heck I did another one where I there
were 4050 Trump protesters inside the
capital this was in the beginning of
2020 January 2020 4050 Trump protesters
inside the capital I I go there to
interview them the next day I showed up
with a piece of tape over my mouth that
said censored I got arrested I spent 36
hours in jail for that now the next day
when that charge reached the judge's
docket he threw it out and completely
dismissed it so I don't have any charges
for that but the point is 40 to 50 Trump
protesters can be in there in the
Capital One prot Trump protester stands
there with a piece of tape over his
mouth he gets arrested and so really all
of that was the background and that's
why they put me in jail I'm thinking a
lot about protests lately I mentioned
this a little bit before the show I
talked to Jacob Chanley earlier today
who was the American Shaman who was also
at the capital and uh we did an
interview on my channel on YouTube which
is it was nice and I was like I think
the thing about protest is the evolution
of protesting right now is it's good to
be out on the street yelling like thing
is bad thing is bad but you just kind of
want to acknowledge the thing and then
offer your solution and the protest the
forward Testament the the the pro the
positive that's the real protest the the
idea that you want to scream about bad
has to go away obviously you want to
educate people what it is but offer them
the solution and I think you can do it
online there is online censorship
unfortunately but a lot of times when
you're not screaming thing is bad on the
internet you don't get censored if
you're screaming this is the solution
people listen and that's a great way to
shift protest well a lot of people are
are afraid to protests I remember there
was a couple other protests that were
happening a couple months ago and
everyone online is saying hey don't show
up there's going to be Feds that are
going to infiltrate and cause an event
just like they did on this one
particular date uh don't show up don't
do it so so this works in many different
ways I think the fear aspect is one of
the most important ones and this is why
I think Owen it's so important for you
to come out and talk and say hey I made
it through I they put me in the system I
made it out I'm stronger I'm better than
ever that message is so important
because it shows us okay uh they could
go after you they could punish you but
guess what you're going to come out on
the other side you're still are going to
uh be um there no matter what they kind
of throw at you that message is more
important I don't know if you you would
probably say it a little bit better but
I want to kind of leave this kind of
open-ended statement for you and kind of
where do you see things going from here
well I would just say that I've kind of
just lived that I mean I haven't I
haven't stopped talking since I got out
I mean I've probably done like 20 or so
interviews um I'm here tonight on uh on
this show it's going to get millions of
views you know I would say that it it's
something that's hard to deal with when
you're in there right it's something
that's hard to deal with when you're
actually in there but if you truly
believe in your cause and you truly
believe in your actions then you can
find that this is not going to be done
in vain that there is going to be a
positive result uh on the other side of
this and I mean maybe there will be
something big in my case maybe not but I
think that it at least as far as getting
the issues out and getting the message
out and getting the awareness out it's
already had a major impact I mean they
brought it up at the Bop hearing and now
a lot of members of Congress and
presidential candidates are kind of
re-evaluating this whole situation not
just with January 6th but just just
overall the persecution that goes on in
this country and the situation that
people are facing uh locked away in
jails when it's nonviolent criminals
victimless crime criminals so but but to
you know to answer your
question I would I would much rather I I
don't want my fate to be controlled or I
don't want my image to be controlled by
the people that hate me and want to
silence me I want to be the one that
controls it so like you said I don't
want people to say oh I'm afraid to talk
or oh I'm afraid to do this or I'm
afraid to take action or I'm afraid to
do a protest I want people to say no I I
want to do it even more now I think it's
important that I stand for my cause and
I think it's important that I don't live
in fear when I'm doing this I it's
important that I don't censor myself I I
don't have this chilling effect or I
don't stay home thinking this is the
safe thing for me me to do is just stay
out of the way so I'm hoping that that
my story goes that way instead of the
way certainly the Democrats or the
establishment we wanted is they see my
case and they say oh I've got to shut up
now I hope people see my case and they
say oh I've got to get louder now I got
I was thinking about um so many things
and I I was just about to I just lost my
train of thought I'll get it back you
got to type it down on your computer
that's true that's what Luke I got I got
the notes I got the papers I'm things
down uh it's important especially for
you know people who procreated U
substances I won't
get uh it's okay Ed it's totally fine
you were so I heard that twitch was uh
trying to allow nudity and then didn't
they learn pretty Qui it wasn't nudity
it was like it was like near close to I
know there's jiggling and oils I was
talk about was a lot the discretion of
using the internet talking on the
internet because the internet's pretty
new and people are still figuring out
how to use it cuz like I'll sit around
in war game with my friends and be like
well what I really think about what that
government did with that is this false
flag thing and and this could have
happened and it's very likely or
possible that this but when I go on the
internet I don't want to say that out
loud because in case I'm wrong and a lot
of times I'm like I'm pretty sure I'm
right but just in case I'm wrong it
could cause like death and destruction
and incompatibility and I don't want to
I don't want to do that and I also think
it's people are watching and listening
and they're like I hope he's not say but
like it's just there's more a
responsibility when the cameras are on
if someone hacks you talking on your
Alexa and they they hear it and then
they post you're talking you didn't put
it on the internet someone else did and
they're responsible for that message but
if you if you proactively put your
message out there and you're just
spitballing there's a lot of
responsibility behind that so I've been
kind of quiet about like wargaming like
the milit because like the conflict's on
Earth right now I want to talk about
what's going on in Israel I just don't
do it on the internet because I don't
know I don't have the proof and I'm not
going to I'm not even going to going to
question this this that stuff it's just
war is a different game because there
are no rules in that kind of thing and I
don't want to bring that down upon
myself um and that's I've been thinking
about that since the since the Israeli
conflict uh since October but here's
what you know you're anti-war big time
so there you go so that's what you know
not necessarily there are just Wars wars
of Defense when the US went to war in
World War II I think they had to they
had to step up um I'm anti- Conquest for
this uh in a lot of ways I don't think
but but there are times when I think it
is necessary to C for National Defense I
I kind of have a question for you you
you were in there for what is it 40 plus
days 47 what was the most kind of
uplifting moment uh or inspiring moment
uh when you were in there definitely all
the letters that I received I mean I I
received I don't know how many at least
500 maybe closer to a thousand and just
reading the positive words from people
supportive words from people some some
people got like some people got really
personal like telling me extremely
personal stories some people uh told me
War Stories some people uh you know
talked about struggles that they went
through some people who had been in
prison before talked about things that
they did to get through their time so
really it was just it was the people and
you know I said that I've said this a
couple times that cuz I understand why
people lose faith in the American people
or even in in the idea of America with
everything that we're going through but
reading that from people and and some of
the people I talked to on the inside
both workers at the prison and the
inmates my my faith in the American
people was reaffirmed I mean it truly
was I I have a deep faith in the
American people I really do and I think
at the end of the day I mean that's what
built this country was the people that
lived here it was the American people
and it's going to have to be the
American people that restore it or or
rebuild it from everything that's been
ripped out from under us I mean you look
at our major some of the greatest cities
in the world at one point St Louis
Baltimore Chicago major major they've
been destroyed they've been destroyed
we've been lapped by cities in the
Middle East and cities in China and the
Far East why because it's been stolen
and it's been destroyed I believe that
we can rebuild I believe that we can
restore and and I believe that the
American people still has the soul and
the spirit to do it we've just kind of
been asleep we've kind of been in a
trance we've kind of been poisoned by
the food and the water but uh I I do
believe it's possible it's going to be
the American people it's not going to be
the president of the United States it's
not going to be anybody in congress
that's how we help ourselves politically
but it's going to have to be the
American people that rebuild this we
need good policy obviously but
ultimately my faith in the American
people was restored I mean the letters
that I got were just I mean truly they
were inspirational they they got me
through some of the hardest times really
you get any chicks trying to date
you
uh that's a yes taking the fifth can
they did they send it like can they send
photos or anything like that yeah you
can send photos okay what's your how how
long you're you're uh you're still on
probation is it yeah uh for a year see
see boys it's not all bad okay I I just
want
to like a bad boy you know what they do
and Hey listen we're we're all in this
same field here let's be honest here um
there's a there's a level of danger for
speaking the truth in a whole empire of
Lies there's there's a there's a layer
of holy freaking cow I could go to jail
for expressing political thought and
expressions I could go to jail for
expressing my truth it's not that bad
you'll get love letters and some nice
ladies messaging you so it's going to be
fine it's it's cool figure it out but
how about you got we got to weigh your
options boys you got weigh how about we
go to super chats if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and uh we're going to
read your super chats but first head
over to the best song ever.com download
the song where it says download name
your price and you will get when you
download the whole package a file with a
unique code if you go to Casper
35% off all your coffee purchases I hope
we sell out I hope we just sell all the
coffee we have but uh if you buy the
song you're helping us basically storm
our way onto the Billboard charts but
not just us Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles of the daily wire also have
writing credits on this they wrote the
song and in the event sometime down the
road we sell 500,000 of these we get a
gold record and uh they can't ignore us
when we do something like that but
eventually one of these days now I get
to say how awesome the song is and you
know what I'm talking about cuz you
listen to it it's uh is spect Carter
Banks nice work that's right all right
Clint Torres says howdy people howdy
clints you are of course number one all
right Shane H Wilder says who knew the
timcast cover of together again was
actually what Tenacious D was singing
about in tribute congrats uh it's
actually true yeah I did think about
that when you said the title of the song
Everybody did the best song ever all the
comments are like tenacious de I'm like
well you know have you been contacted by
Jack Black yet Tenacious D they were
actually singing about Stairway to
Heaven in if you see their original uh
HBO special where the tenaciousd got
their start it was they play a little uh
Stairway to Heaven Rift but then when
they made the movie they didn't have the
copyright so they had to make a song up
ah stairway apparently tribute yep let's
grab some more Super chats Ramon G
Stanley Jr says Carter Tim we should go
get some ice cream Tim yeah I agree then
uh that' make a Killer music video part
two can be you guys using a claw machine
we're going to we're I think the one we
we we did with Ian where Ian actually
gained like 25 lbs of raw muscle or
whatever I don't know that one that one
might be coming out in January or might
get pushed back we have another song
that there's more um electronic and
upbeat the one with Ian is like a horror
song it's like creepy sounds and like
pretty weird yeah it was technically
describe as a horror song Maybe about 14
pounds of muscle fat water all that kind
of stuff but yeah you know we'll see so
that's where the 15 lbs I lost in prison
went I took it from you man I dream I
got to get that back I yeah so what's
your plan how you doing it I'm just
lifting as many heavy weights as I can
until I can get back to where I was at I
saw you said you you're about you were
started about 20% of where you were at
25 or something it was like 10 the first
time about 20 the second time I'm
probably about like maybe maybe getting
close to 30 it's it's coming back a
little a little quicker than I thought
if I if I was measuring it out I used to
be able to do a um a deadlift front
squat press uh with 170 lbs and uh I I
put up I think 13 or 140 I put up 140 so
I lost 30 lbs on that which is probably
the toughest the toughest weight lift uh
that I would do so it's slowly coming
back but I mean really it's just you're
starving all the time you're sleep
deprived all the time I'm going to get
it back to I look at it as a challenge I
don't look at it like a setback I look
at it like a challenge and uh that's how
you got to look at these situations in
life all right Micah Johnson says Tim
what is the process for Redeeming the
30% it's 35% Casper discount after
buying the best song ever love the show
thank you for what you do so it's only
if you bought it from the best song
ever.com and then it says download name
your price you click that and it'll it's
it's the minimum is 69 cents but you can
give whatever you want you will get a
download with the song and a folder and
the folder has a file which contains
your unique code you can use if you go
to casper.com so I'm telling you guys if
you want to buy coffee and you should
let's say you want to buy one bag of say
Raz Roberto Jr per month do the
subscription option use the code and
that 35% will be forever and I'll stress
this again let's say 6 months later
you're like I'm canceling my cash brew
and then 3 months after that you're like
I want to start again you still get the
35% what if you have one bag a month you
cancel it and you're like I want to
subscribe for three bags a month does
that disrupt the
code I think it would still uh yeah I
think new subscriptions would not have
the code and alterations of sub I'll can
put it this way you could subscribe to
10 bags per month right now with the
code and then cancel right away get
those 10 bags and then later on down the
line a year from now you could buy 10
bags with a subscription and the code
would apply and then you could cancel it
right away and for the rest of your life
you will have that discount I'm saying
it's a good deal go to the best song
ever.com good coffee too I like that
pumpin spice dude we we we actually sell
out of Appalachia Knights is the top
seller and we're we go through it like
crazy it's nuts we're constantly have to
having to reorder it's like when you
order it you're basically getting
something that was that was that was uh
roasted like a few days before like
super you sell more whole bean or ground
ground yeah people aren't buying whole
bean yeah so we're going to we're going
to reduce the amount of whole bean we
carry but we're still going to have
it Sam good says it was so hard to find
the video to the point where I had to go
to a non-mobile website to even find it
your Shadow ban must be back because of
Owen perhaps well I'm sorry I've been
trying to I've been trying to buy ads on
Google and they're just in pending
review and I'm like that's weird
normally when we run ads it's like
instantly just it goes this one not so
much just but we uh we are running ads
on X as well and so far we have $45,000
in ads on X for the song cuz like I said
we're going to be spending I I pledged
advertisements on X we're doing it and
we're going to do more dude it has
221,000 views on YouTube it actually has
more than that that those those are
front facing so whenever you look at the
numbers displayed on any YouTube video
the actual numbers behind the scene
could be three to five times higher it
really just depends Kent Welling man his
voice acting is incredible oh and and it
was funny cuz uh the daily wire crew was
like can you send us the script for the
video and I was like there is none we ad
lied all of it it's just all just we
pressed go and we said
stuff let's go what do we have alad says
hi Tim shout out to together again you
guys did an amazing job the video is
awesome Tommy Mack released a pop synth
song as well great minds huh that's
right we got to do a song with Tom
McDonald that'd be great but this it's
the first day the song's been up we have
all till next week to uh uh get the
charts I think if we sell like 50,000
that's that's around where you hit
billboard Hot 100 and that's really the
like that's the fingers crossed let's
get this so the daily wire is doing a
big push as well it because the writing
credit goes to Jeremy Borg and Michael
nolles and then we get we get a like a
cover credit like it's like a modern
writing credit or whatever but uh the
idea that we could get onto their charts
when they get when they when we said hey
guys we have a song they said go f
yourself we're like number one we
released this the first song we put out
and we're charting across the board and
they told us to go f ourselves the only
way to force them to have to write about
it and I'm sure they'll talk smack or
whatever is to just push harder and
harder onto the charts this is like a I
think this is just a winner well we'll
see we'll see I mean I got to be honest
only uana did did uh better than I I
realized it did yeah like it actually
did remarkably well and when we compare
it to the metrics for for our later
music earlier music and other stuff that
other people have put out I'm like wow
actually that song did really good the
response was really great too people
were interested for whatever reason all
right Daniel galazo says Alex Jones
Infowars is getting DD NATO approves
Ukraine plus nine other countries World
War III is about to start wait NATO
approved Ukraine did that just happen I
don't think so I hear about it yeah I'm
like that that's like apocalyptic levels
of uh but they're getting desperate so I
wouldn't be surprised if they try to
pull that there's going to be something
that they're going to try to pull yeah
okay the latest is just that Biden says
it will happen in the future so is that
guy also lying about the DS attack I
don't know I don't know I haven't heard
anything about that from the crew so but
that that stuff happens all the time
Paul just endorsed Viv yeah he invited
him to his fight tonight yep a video
going around Jak Paul saying uh you know
I'm officially he's awesome super cool
you should reach out to him he's great
I'd love to get uh uh Jake or Logan on
the show Jake Jake's the man I mean
Logan too but Jake Jak I'm actually I'm
a big fan of Logan Jake Jak I don't know
a lot about they're Ohio boys they're
from my my area I've heard Logan talk
about hard work entrepreneurship and
success and stuff and I'm like this guy
gets it that's why he is where he is I
respect it shout out plus like I respect
them like training to fight and do what
they want to do they know how to get
attention and they work very hard ex
great marketing yeah man okay Jeremy B
says hey Luke what is your take on
Donald Tusk getting elected uh not good
uh he's a essentially a globalist and
this is not really good for the people
of Poland so I'm not happy about it how'
he get
elected uh good question uh there
there's been a of immigration into
Poland from Ukraine um there's been a
lot of scandals with the church too uh
predominantly Poland is 90% Catholic but
uh there's been a lot of scandals with
the church as well that failed a lot of
people so I don't know it's hard to kind
of um understand it myself Dylan visit
own says I pre-ordered the song it's
okay doesn't live up to the hype though
kind of disappointed just my opinion
shout out to Eric jly I have a pile of
signed Comics thanks well Dylan I mean
that's fine Jeremy boring the one who
wrote it don't look at me like all the
writing credit goes to Jeremy and
Michael nlls oh wow so your opinion you
you got to take it are you listening to
with enough bass Dylan try it with make
sure your if the device you have it on
the B you're allowed to not like music
you're not you're allowed to not like
certain kinds of art the reality is we
put out some songs and then everyone's
like wow this is my This Is My Jam I
love this style other people are like I
hate this kind of music and I'm like
well yeah of course like I don't listen
to Country so it's like if if some put a
country song I just be like yeah not my
jam you know whatever have a nice day
all right where we
at what have we dick Dickerson says I
can't believe Ian beat a kid because the
kid made fun of graphine Luke created a
monster fake news but if you see the
music video you'll know what he's
talking about oh that that picture of
Ian is so good yeah he's in cuffs in a
jumpsuit he's going to jail y here we go
the trooper says before the first Civil
War we had a caning in the Senate now we
got a pegging things are going to get
weird this
time that's a good one that's a good one
well done yikes all right all right what
do we got what do we
got legma says may I offer a limmer in
these trying times two staffers in a
wrestle of lust in the Senate aroused
our disgust filming their tussle causing
quite a bustle their cheeky Caper a
humorous thrust the memes are already
popping up on on X it was well done but
it's too much it's too heavy the memes
of like US Government taxpayer and good
we need that jeez
that's what that's what's really going
on in
there let's go Paul Jones say I got
introduced to Eric through this podcast
been waiting for you to have him back
good to see Luke back as well oh shout
up appreciate you yeah right on always
good
fun pretty much media says Tim and Eric
my partner and I are working on creating
a media company to make comics cartoons
and music video games and music and
video games we're about to launch a
campaign for a graphic novel any advice
for building up to be a successful
company wo man uh look with
I don't want people to get the wrong
idea you know looking at our success and
thinking kind of it's just one of those
things that just happened and it's not
you know I've been kind of building
doing creative things for the better
part of the last 18 years um or so so I
think that that's kind of where you
start um and that's kind of being
personable interacting with people U
building some sort of audience of people
that uh you can depend on uh building
that Rapport and in order to sort of do
that you kind of have to deliver not
kind of you absolutely have to deliver
on whatever product it is that you
you're um going to put out there so my
advice um shout out to you and your
aspirations but my advice would be to
pick one of those you I guess you said
the graphic and Al you're starting with
that that's a great place to start um
just make sure it's U best to your
ability it doesn't need to be perfect
but make sure it's to the best of your
ability and take that thing serious
because that's going to be your first
impression from from your audience so
don't cut any slack um or any Corner
excuse me with anything it is that you
you do but you're going to have to get
out there and be a lot more interactive
I think that's the future of
entertainment now because people have uh
been burned and giving money to people
that kind of hate them so uh people want
to know who they're giving their money
to so uh start there though but shout
out to you man I wish you nothing but
the
best right on let's grab some more call
me Josh says I suppose the slippery
slope fallacy isn't really a fallacy at
all is it I mean here we are living the
nightmare acceptance doesn't mean we
have to accept everything I mean that
that's one Mee people were putting out
there where it was like 2008 hey look
just because two you know two people who
love each other want to get married
doesn't mean they're going to go bang in
the senate floor or something like that
well here we are here we
are let's grab uh some more Super chats
Wyatt calenberg says oh and how did the
prison guards treat you did they see you
as a political prisoner or did they see
you as An Enemy of the State so there
was a little bit of a mixed reaction um
some of them knew who I was before I
even got in there and liked me some of
them knew who I was before I got in
there and didn't like me but that was a
lot smaller of a number um by day 10
pretty much everybody in there knew who
I was and had an opinion one way or the
other the amount of times I heard I'm
just doing my job like hey I love you
and what you do but I'm just doing my
job is uh far too many to
count um unfortunat so you know here's
what it go here's
where this is why it's not necessarily
about me the treatment that I received
in prison is what most people in prison
experience at at some time or in some
way shape or form but because I'm
blessed with a large following and a
large platform you're just hearing about
what I went through um my story The
solitary um I mean I'm there's all kinds
of stories I go they stole or lost all
my property uh just all the craziness
and by the way I'm writing a book about
all this it'll probably come out next
year all the crap that I went through
just generally speaking a lot of the
treatment of prisoners is you're just a
number you're not a human nobody gives a
crap about you nobody on the inside
gives a crap about you nobody on the
outside gives a crap about you we can do
whatever the hell we want to you and
none of it matters but because I have a
large platform and a large following a
lot of what I had to go through and I
experienc is actually is actually coming
out and making it to the front so I mean
really just generally speaking prisoners
are not treated with much respect or
dignity at all uh and we're talking
about nonviolent criminals we're talking
about victimless crime criminals we're
talking about um people who have
families waiting for them at home they
really are just treated with with very
little respect and dignity and so it's
it's really a sad thing and that's not
even a political thing about me I mean
there were definitely probably some
people in there that that didn't like my
politics and maybe wanted to make it as
hard on me as possible but it was It was
kind of far few and far between
generally speaking prisoners are are
disrespected and look if you're a high
level prisoner and you killed or raped
somebody then you know what I'm not
really shedding a tear for you or you're
a child molester or stuff like that I'm
not really shedding a tear for those
people but uh it's it's just amazing how
you're you're completely discounted a as
a human and any human emotions or
feelings that that you might have as a
prisoner just completely discounted and
they they treat you like you need to
just be numb to all this and you just
have to accept that you're a prisoner
and you're going to be treated like this
so uh you know my my
treatment had a bunch of curveballs and
knuckle balls but really for my 47 days
I just experienced everything somehow I
just experienced everything that that
prisoners experience every day and
so the larger story isn't really about
me it's that we desperately need prison
reform I mean it it's desperate a lot a
lot of the higher ups at these
prisons I I'll close it like this
there's three types of people that work
at prisons there's the incompetent and
inept people the the you know stereotype
of they just snap on the job and then
there's the power Trippers and anytime
they get a chance to just trip on their
power and just put you in your place and
feel good about thems they're going to
do it every time and then some and then
there's the friendlies if you respect
them they're going to respect you um but
just generally speaking my story is one
thing but prisoners a lot of these
prisoners non-violent criminals
victimless crime criminals they're just
they're they're treated like subhumans
they're disrespected they're discounted
they barely even get a scrap of dignity
the way they're treated in there and so
it's not just about me it's a story that
I'm going to have to tell my story but
but it's it's really what goes on in
these prisons every
day I just have to uh take a screenshot
real quick of this uh tweet so it's my
tweet saying was he the guy getting
effed in the a or was was he the guy
effing some other guy in the a and then
everyone started saying like oh blah
blah blah Tim and I said well it matters
because we need to know if that's him on
camera or for he's filming then if if
he's filming how how do we determine it
was him we don't want to falsely accuse
someone of you know I'm I'm being I'm
keeping the language light it's not what
I tweeted fing a guy in the A on the
sent hearing room floor the rabbit hole
said never deleting this app rated X for
everyone and Elon Musk uh liked it and
laughed at it so I'm just going to have
to retweet that real quick rated X for
everyone
yeah that's awesome totally worth it X
is the place to be imagine imagine if
it's the guy who's who's receiving who
invites his buddy in and and then he
films it and destroys his life and he's
like man why'd you have to do this to me
yeah if he didn't know he was being
recorded oh yeah crazy I mean not
justifying the behavior obviously I'm
just talking from that level at a
personal level it's like jam damn dude
you really had to film me like I didn't
even know you were doing that now I'm
all over the Internet well I guess
that's what you get karma's a all
right the yeti 90 says if the doj and
police would do their job all the
corrupt politicians and and Leos would
be legally arrested and if they if they
were they wouldn't have to worry about
being fired or losing money Trump V 2024
I'd rather build a system that like
disallows corruption than try and like
whack-a-mole all the corruption when it
pops up if we can build like Le less
corruptible systems that'd be nice I
don't know if you'll ever be able to
stop corruption if it's potential if
it's available so what do you think just
shut down the systems well no I like
smart contracts like if instead of like
just relying on 4 50 Representatives if
each of those 700,000 people they each
have one representative could like vote
on a smart contract yes or no and then
that would go to a system and then that
one repres that thing would go yes or no
so you don't have these Representatives
that get bribed uh you would remove that
corruption Source from the system that
could be one potential minor solution in
some way I'd say just shut down all
these corrupt Federal operations shut
them all down I think the biggest
problem is those guards you mentioned
who are like hey man I'm just doing my
job
that is if I was going to if I was going
to say like on a scale of 1 to 10 where
one is it's not really a problem at all
things are pretty good and 10 is it's
the worst problem our society faces it's
those guards are 10 you can talk about
like Nancy Pelosi and Joe Biden all that
and those are like seven eights and
nines to varing degrees like big
problems for our society but the the
only reason any of it exists is because
good men do nothing yeah and I think if
we're looking okay so what's the what's
the scenario what's the outcome that we
would be looking for they should have
just released me day one imagine if
every prison guard went to their boss
and said I will not do any work related
to Owen Shroyer good luck and every
single guard was just like I ain't going
anywhere near it or they just said we're
not going to process him we're not going
to throw him in and then if the federal
government puts out a warrant they just
say no we're not going to arrest him
well I mean so you end up showing up and
you're standing there being like tell me
what to do and all the guards are like
nope we're on strike what would they do
they could do nothing the problem is
yeah absolutely by all means call in
people who will do it fine but these
these spineless cowards who are like I
like what you do and I I believe in you
and you're right and now I'm going to
facilitate the evil of this nation while
staring you in the eyes talk about
scumbags dude I don't I I'm I'm sorry
man anybody who tries playing that I'm
just doing my job game to me you are the
most despicable disgusting cre it's the
ethos of what the Nazis did my whole
life I was told that they were like all
these Nazi soldiers were just like I'm
just following orders I'm just following
orders and they knew what they were
doing was immoral but they're like I'm
just following order not I'm not saying
all of them but there were a lot of them
that said that all of the people learned
that was my all of those people saying
I'm just doing my job are lifting up the
corrupt and the evil and bearing their
weight so they can destroy this country
and then everyone says yeah but they've
got families and they've got kids it's
really really difficult I'm like I get
it I get it your family is more
important in the future your children
will have it's more important than being
the hero who's going to fight to do
something good totally understand you've
made your priority is clear I can't say
anything about it I don't have kids well
Tim I'm I'm I'm glad that you showed the
emotion on this topic because it's
really something that's hard to
encapsulate especially when I've dealt
with it so many times the first time
when they arrested me and they all knew
it was wrong they knew it was wrong they
said I'm sorry but I'm just doing my job
the second time they arrested me and
they knew it was wrong sorry I'm just
doing my job the third time like you're
saying when I'm go even even some of the
FBI guys that came and were dealing with
my uh indictment said sorry I'm just
doing my job I've had to they and you
say it when you're staring it in the
face and that actually happens to you
it's it's it's impossible to explain I
mean it really is you want to know why
on this scale sural Epstein is a nine
and those cops are a 10 because if those
cops didn't exist Epstein would have
been dealt with instantly y think about
the level of government involvement what
Epstein was doing where they had to
protect him you know it's a fact with
those flights and and and look you've
got presidents flying on those planes
Secret Service is involved and those
Secret Service guys are like well I know
what's going on but I'm just doing my
job
those guys are the problem children came
to the FBI in the 1990s and talked about
what EP was doing the FBI ignored them
let's not forget about the media let's
not forget about the media's role in
this Amy robach at ABC hot tape oh I was
going to bring up the Clinton Epstein
story but uh they told me not to do it
so I'm not going to do it well guess
what now she's gotten all the promotions
she's on the big daytime show she's
making more money than I thought she got
fired because she was dating that guy
they did have some Fallout I guess one
of them was cheating on their spouse or
whatever no I don't think they were I
think they were just in a relationship
and they were co-anchors or whatever and
it was a scandal some people are saying
she released it uh deliberately right
the hot tape that that she's the one who
leaked it because the story should have
gotten out and she helped it get out
that way well the point is the media was
covering it up too oh yeah absolutely no
they were promoting Epstein they were
saying he's a great guy he all the
stories they wrote about I'm not so mad
at her I gota be honest because she's on
camera being like they stopped me I was
trying to do it and it's a 50-50
situation where it's like well you
should have still done something but
maybe she was the one who leaked it I
don't know it's different if she said
something like so I helped them cover it
up then I'd be like okay she's evil but
she didn't she said she wanted to get it
out and she had the story and she's
pissed they suppressed it on her and
then uh well shout out to James o for
doing the hard work uh oh we have the
shirt it is out do you want to see it we
can't show it here we can't show it to
any second how did they get this angle
listen my team works very hard my team
the question here we go team very
hard the shirt is you do you want to
purify your eyes here's a here's a
here's a calendar of here's a calendar
of hot chicks if you need wait what how
did they get this angle Len my team I
have the best team out there the best
political shirts.com shouts out to to
everyone including Josh look at Ian's
face put Ian's face on there this is now
available for everyone aw right now on
the best political
I'm buying mine right now and uh thank
you because you do and you support my
Independent Media organization too at
the same time so appreciate you guys if
we living it again if we lived in a
world where uh I'll give this shout out
to Matt Walsh and I think Matt would
agree if we lived in a world where man
of conscience refused to do immoral acts
that satanic statue wouldn't even be in
the Capitol Building because all it
takes is for for the people working
there to say I'm not I'm not going to do
that I am not going we need you to come
in and work security they're gonna be
something a satanic statue no I won't
show up have a nice day no instead it's
like you got it boss hey man I don't
like it but I'm just doing my job well
this is why we call them the you know
lucal feel me on this why we call them
especially the enforcers the teeth right
of the state so we can you mention
Pelosi or we talk about aocc or whoever
it is at the end of the day the guys
that that are going to be front lines
and the first conflict it is that you
are going to have is with the police
that's just a no matter what the
conflict uh it is it that's going to be
the first line of of defense and if you
know they were on their stuff let's just
say that and they actually believed they
were serving and protecting the
individuals uh within this geographical
area they would just simply say no um
and again I mean this isn't my quote but
the old quote is Tom was talking about
this it's like hey you know they talk
about doing their jobs right and I guess
the answer to that is maybe you
shouldn't exactly Sparks says Tim if
Disney signed a $100 million deal with X
would you also call that a quote win
that one's a bit more tough because
Disney was already advertising on X so
there's nothing there there's no re
there's no rectifying anything uh I
would call it a win would I call it
absolute Victory or anything like that
well I don't know about that I'd say
winning doesn't mean you won the War
sometimes you win the battles and
sometimes you make small gains so if
there's a major uh like there's a major
Battlefield with the Confederates and
the Union Soldiers and the Confederates
you know open fire and take out a
commander would you call that a win well
like in the colloquial sense of like it
was good for them at the time it doesn't
mean they won the battle then the union
comes in and crushes them you know what
I mean but my point is simply uh did you
guys see what Sean Strickland tweeted
out today no I have not he said he he
let me let me uh let me read it can you
tell us I can absolutely I can
absolutely read this one sean shik Shawn
was family friendly this time yes oh all
right uh let me uh let me scroll down
here and find the Tweet cuz I retweeted
it don't you love how the the realest
men in America in sports are all in MMA
like that's not that's not by chance
that's why I'm saying it's good they're
getting money Sean Strickland said
unpopular opinion January 6 was the most
patriotic thing our country has done in
a very long time to which I responded
thank you budlight for sponsoring this
message do they sponsor him or something
they sponsor UFC okay and he's a
champion so that money goes to him and
when he he's made the he made political
statements in the past he said brought
to you by Bud Light in some manner of
speaking so like I tell you roll baby a
foreign multinational company I don't
think that they would be that upset
watching the US tear itself apart so
maybe they are getting what they want
out of it I don't know my point is he's
he he keeps spinning on the left and so
far budlight has done anheiser bush has
said and done nothing they just keep
letting him do it and so I'm I'm hey
look man keep boycotting everything else
side can we at least enjoy that like we
can all agree well I I'll tell you this
fun because even though uh inbev which
is based in Belgium bought anheiser Bush
I guess it was like 10 years ago or so
now most of the a lot of the creative
decisions still come out of St Louis
Missouri my hometown so I still know a
lot of people in that process I wouldn't
say there's a civil war within you know
budlight or their marketing team but
let's just say there's like your hard
conservative Wing inside and then
there's like oh we got to cater to the
left for all these marketing purposes
inside and they're kind of always like
showing each other numbers and saying
look you you were miserable over here or
look we should have done this so it's
kind of a back and forth with all of it
so it doesn't surprise me that Bud Light
when they see this stuff they're like
let him go we're not we're not touching
this we already suffered a billion
dollar market cap with that uh you know
gay
whatever all right uh let's uh here we
go what is this one where do we at uh
talking taking back toxic says the
statue is a red herring why is there
even a government building fort to be
inside in the first place AA
AA aera indeed damn right why was there
a government building for it to be
inside in the first place because walls
they protect you from arrows I don't
know why did they build walls in the
first way cuz rain you got to protect
yourself from the elements all right oh
we got a sting bug he's chilling what's
he doing he's been hanging out all time
he's your government
probe see you later s strong y yeah
they're pretty cool that's a uh that's a
government stink bug it's a brown
marmorated stink bug introduced into the
United hey hey come on Tim he's just
trying to do his job about 1996 they
from China he's just doing his job man
he can't even get up all right let's uh
torted like a turtle alien robot go says
if you have a million dollar today or
$10 million in 5 years which would you
choose well that's a long complicated
question but I'd suppose of course today
$10 million is $10 million in five years
is just basically toilet paper basic the
way this country is going if you know
how to invest that money now would be
the time all right everybody if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net pull it off next week it's
it's a holiday season so we'll see if it
works out but ultimately it's it's a
similar campaign to what we had you know
the first time around we are we are
trying to force them to acknowledge that
we drive sales we have an impact and we
have a bigger impact than many other
artists who struggle to even get
anywhere where we are I'll tell you this
right now forward facing the music video
has like 200 and some odd K that's
bigger than many mainstream signed bands
already and they keep just telling us to
screw ourselves so we're just going to
keep pushing but uh again the best song
ever.com Owen do you want to shout
anything out yeah please follow me I'm
back on Twitter I got released from jail
and then I got released from the Twitter
jail uh right afterwards it was great so
my personal count is back at all I do is
Owen and then for my political media we
share stuff like this clips from this
show that I'm on uh timcast the clips
will put there at Owen Shroyer 1776 but
uh the Big Show the big platform 3 hours
a day 3: to 6:00 p.m. weekdays at band
.v video/ warro or the easier link might
be Owen Shroyer doow and then I do a
rumble show as well on my own we have a
little fun we loosen it up a little bit
rumble.com oen great to be back here Tim
thank
you oh yeah well just go to ri.com we're
smack dab in the middle of a campaign
for you guys that are want to get into
Comics you want an alternative go to
riper verse.com alphacord number one is
the campaign we're in right now it's
wrote by the legendary Chuck Dixon you
know him as the creator of Bane he did a
lot of um uh DC Comic stuff all
throughout the 90s all the bat family
stuff well he's the writer here as well
as Joe Bennett being the artist uh it's
a little police procedural uh with
superhero elements um if you're into
that right now we're at like almost 1
uh2 million uh dollars on this campaign
orders are already going out since we
started fulfillment early last week so
just go to revere.com and you'll check
it out there but man it does feel good
to be back here man I appreciate
appreciate you having me I've been here
all day right on yeah this was a great
show thank you so much for uh for
everyone being here Owen it's great that
you're not in jail anymore so thank you
so much for joining us you could send me
your love letters on
youtube.com wear change and then my web
guy just messaged me he's like we're
getting hit with some attacks from
Australia and all IPS uh so it looks
like the best political charts.com is
down for now I'm going to be posting
alternative links um on Twitter as well
lukee are change so if you want to see
the delcious uh very uh perfect shirt
for family gatherings uh and this
holiday Christmas is coming up this is
the gift you get your crazy uncle or if
you're the crazy uncle you got to wear
it we can't show it to you here on um
Twitter at Luke are change I'm going to
let you know when the Dos attacks stop
on my websites and then we'll be able to
purchase the shirts and support my
Independent Media organization it's
we're at a period in time right now
where you have a lot of power like uh a
lot a lot of power and you can do a lot
of good and work within your community
to strengthen your bonds your
friendships your family um forgive
people that have hurt you in the past
Now's the Time and uh we can move
forward and transition this whole world
into something new and really cool and
we could do it together one-on-one one
by one and uh thanks again Tim for
throwing that party earlier we had a
wonderful Christmas party company
Christmas party it was super cool shout
out to the gamer Maids on YouTube and I
will be seeing you guys at Turning Point
USA coming up shout out to Dutch's
Daughter it's a restaurant
in the Western Maryland era area and
it's amazing and that's where we got the
catering for the party and everybody
just annihilated all the food thank you
for that the steak were really awesome
Stakes were amazing I was so hungry when
I landed too perfect oh the crab K and
and we're doing a show with Tucker
Carlson Monday super so we'll be seeing
you guys is it gonna is it behind a pay
wall or is it on YouTube I it's on
YouTube awesome soest we'll be seeing
you guys bright and early Monday night
is that where you guys are going after
this uh we're flying out so we we fly
out Sunday we're there just for the one
day and then we fly immediately right
back I I I wasn't allowed to uh
probation didn't allow me to go they
allowed me to come here though they
allowed they did allow my probation
officer allowed me to come here because
uh technically I uh organized this
before I met with him so but after that
I'm locked down shout out to the people
that are working that out man because
it's super cool to have you dude I'm
glad you can
for and we also have this guy to the
right yeah great show Jance that was fun
appreciate you guys both being here glad
to see you out Owen and uh hope you guys
enjoyed the show shows uh not normally
that spicy but today was wild a wild
news story to things up yeah see on the
Discord I'm surge.com you know where I'm
at we will see you all on Monday Tucker
Carlson will be joining us at amfest
we're super excited thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all then
cheers